Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu u k w unsere kleine welt mein name ist tim pride love.
Und ja es wird jetzt hier langsam eine neue regelmäßigkeit entwickelt denn es gibt gerade einfach so viel zu diskutieren und zu reflektieren und auch dafür ist dieser kanal gedacht,
rund um die korona krise ergibt sich natürlich jetzt derzeit nahezu alles und insofern.
Habe ich mir auch gedacht,
ist es auch ganz gut ein regelmäßigen kanal zu etablieren wo man all diese ganzen informationen die uns jetzt gerade so um segeln und die der interpretation harren.
Diese diskutiert und ja dafür begrüße ich erstmal wieder den pavel hallo pavel.
Denn wir haben jetzt schon zwei mal gesprochen das erste mal so also deine.
Ganzen recherche aktivitäten und eigene experimente mit zahlenwerk aufgenommen hast letzte woche dann ein zweites mal.
Ja und ich hab so den eindruck das ist eigentlich immer ein ganz guter anlass hier einmal die woche mal zu schauen wie sich das alles so weiterentwickelt und dann in der folge vielleicht auch die ganzen anderen diskussionen die mittlerweile losgegangen sind.
Ein wenig einzuordnen und zu schauen.
Es gab ja viel reaktionen auch in den kommentaren am anfang ob denn das alles so eine gute.
Idee ist sich da so drauf zu stürzen und eigeninterpretations vorzunehmen aber ich muss sagen ich bin eigentlich immer überzeugt davon dass es durchaus notwendig ist.
All das ganze mal auch neu zu interpretieren denn.
Es ist einfach eine ganze menge und wird langsam unübersichtlich und man merkt auch wie leute anfangen zu schwimmen in all diesen ganzen.
Zahlen werken kurven die man um die ohren geworfen bekommt da irgendwie noch orientierung zu behalten ich weiß nicht wie geht's dir damit.
Ich beschäftige mich halt sehr sehr viel mit den zahlen in den letzten wochen und mich.
Beruhigt das ganze eher zu sehen grundsätzlich dass das was ich heraus bekomme aus den zahlen sich nicht wesentlich unterscheidet was die.
Experten oder die profis oder.
Diejenigen von den profis denen ich vertraue sowie christian rosten beispielsweise was die dazu sagen so also das ist das ist jetzt nicht so dass ich.
Irgendwelche sensationellen neuen erkenntnisse habe sondern im wesentlichen das.
Sich bestätigt was wir offiziell zu hören kriegen meistens weiß ich dann so ein zwei drei tage vorher und das ist dann ganz beruhigend wenn du ein zwei drei tage vorher später aus offiziellen quellen.
Dann sagen die bestätigung kommt und das ist jetzt weitgehend auch so gewesen zur letzten sendung da kam ja dann wiederum,
kritik sagen je nachdem wie du mich vorgestellt hast als als was so bei der letzten sendung und sozusagen,
hatten einige verstanden ich wäre jetzt der ganz tolle großartige experte für das ganze haben wir aber glaube ich so nie behauptet aber bei einigen scheint so angekommen zu sein und
ich,
twittere sie ja sehr viele dieser sachen unter pavel dreiundzwanzig wenn man da auch bilder oder so finden will oder nochmal kann man auch nochmal eine ganze menge von ihm nachlesen so was wir hier heute.
So erzählen werden.
Aber ja ich packe unter twitter unter jedem schritt eigentlich immer so einen disclaimer noch dazu und der lautet dann
meistens so ähnlich wie ich bin einfach nur aus dem internet und kein epidemiologische aber ich versuche zu verstehen und mit meinen mitteln nachvollziehen
zu vollziehen was ich von experten höre um es selbst einordnen und gewichten zu können und es klappt recht gut dass vielleicht vorab.
Ja genau ich denke dass das bringt's auch ganz gut auf den punkt was auch ich versuche hier mit den ganzen sendungen zu machen es wird halt gerade viel berichtet ich denke auch der journalismus.
Mit einschränkungen hat so eine gewisse wiedererwecken auch erfahren vielleicht ist das auch noch ein bisschen meine wahrnehmung aber es wird einfach viel geguckt wird wie gemacht wird auch im ganzen podcast im universum
'ne menge getan und das ist das ist gut so ja teilweise sogar komplett neue podcast formate sich ausschließlich dieser krise widmen.
Wissenschaftskommunikation wissenschaft journalismus erlebt große nachfrage einfach
aus denselben gründen was wie ist das alles einzuordnen was was stimmt jetzt eigentlich wie sind all diese ganzen neuen studien die rein schwappen zu sehen und das ja auch absolut nachvollziehbar.
Dass es diese reaktion gibt.
Ja ich
was halt interessant ist ist dass die medien sich sehr viel mühe gegeben haben so informationen zu prüfen und auch gerade am anfang sagen.
Fast so eine harmonie herrschte aber mittlerweile sieht man ja schon dass da auch ein.
Bisschen versucht wird fronten aufzubauen weil natürlich medien oder.
Es gibt halt diese theorie dass eine sendung umso interessanter ist je kontroverser sie gestaltet wird je mehr die leute darin streiten und das,
ja das kommt halt nicht immer gut an weil es natürlich zu einer polarisierung führt die man halt möglichst vermeiden möchte bei diesem thema aber das steht uns glaube ich so ein
bisschen zunehmend bevor wenn jetzt die zahlen fallen werden und sich alles etwas entspannt werden wir halt glaube ich eine menge streit und auseinandersetzungen hören in den medien und
vielleicht noch eine bemerkung zu den medien etwas lustiges was mir aufgefallen ist ich,
warte mal selber geguckt wann ich eigentlich aufmerksam geworden bin auf das thema war nicht angefangen habe da mitzugehen und wie der wie,
die presse die medien damals darüber berichtet haben und das war im prinzip so das erste mal hatte ich ja mitte januar
so hab ich mal was habe ich mal ein tweet zu korona gemacht und dann so richtig auf dem schirm hab ich's eigentlich seit mitte februar
wo ich da sagen verständnis für maßnahmen und erwartungen dass halt drastische maßnahmen kommen zu der zeit allerdings in den medien fand man.
Berichte im wesentlichen unter der rubrik ausland das charakterisiert die situation vielleicht ganz gut.
Corona lief halt unter ausland so da wurden halt die armen chinesen bedauert und
die rückkehrer aus aus aller welt befragt wie es ihnen denn ergangen ist so im im corona land oder auf auf dem schiff auf der diamond princess und so dass das war halt corona war halt
noch nicht hier,
und das schlug sich dann auch in der presse nieder das änderte sich dann in den darauffolgenden vierzehn tagen dann sehr sehr schnell,
aber ja so das zum thema medien vielleicht.
Gut dann schauen wir doch mal zu beginn auf.
Die zahlen vielleicht noch eine sache vorweg wenn ihr fragen habt oder wenn ihr material habt auf das ihr uns hinweisen wollt dann oder auch pavel konkret hinweisen wollt.
Du hast schon gesagt du bist pavel dreiundzwanzig auf twitter,
das aber auch vor allem gerne in die kommentare zu dieser sendung packen.
Das ist uns ganz recht gesehen vieles aber sicherlich nicht alles und ja das könnte auf jeden fall auch helfen ja die zahlen was.
Lässt sich denn aus dem offiziellen zahlenmaterial was du.
Lies begutachten und hat sich denn deine daten versorgung die wir letzte woche noch so beklagt haben verbessert.
Ja also es ist tatsächlich auch durch twitter und durch die sendung.
Bin ich auf eine datensammlung aufmerksam geworden nämlich dieser dump den ich mir gewünscht hatte.
Sowas gibt es tatsächlich ansatzweise für die visualisierung und dort wurde ich auch offene aufmerksam gemacht wo man.
Tatsächlich eine csv datei so wie ich es mir gewünscht habe mit zumindest den täglichen neuzugängen
herunterladen kann so wo dann sagen für jede meldung ein eintrag in der datenbank steht ist ein
bisschen kompliziert zu interpretieren noch oder
aber es sind auf jeden fall interessante daten über die ich mich noch nicht bisher her gemacht habe aber das tatsächlich auf dem schirm habe.
Bisher gemacht habe war halt im wesentlichen in vier ländern,
bei uns in deutschland italien china und die usa die zahlen zu verfolgen und zu analysieren und auch zu gucken
also wie weil uns etablieren ja voraus ist so wie läuft es da die usa sind uns ein bisschen hinterher in china ist uns schon ganz weit voraus und insofern habe ich mir halt diese vier
länder rausgepickt und.
Für deutschland erstmal was sicherlich für viele am interessantesten ist haben sich die zahlen erwartungsgemäß.
Entwickelt das heißt die infizierten zahlen die zahl der gemeldeten neuinfektionen.
Hat den zenit
überschritten also wir sind definitiv bei der verdoppelung berate und bei der sogenannten netto produktionszeit zahl die
das kann man an den zahlen sehen ist jetzt in den bereich gefallen wo die ausbreitung,
zum halten gekommen ist.
Kannst du nochmal kurz sagen was die verdopplung zahl und die netto reproduktion für daten parameter sind.
Genau also die verdoppelungs-aktion zeit ist die zeit in der sich die zahl der infizierten verdoppelt so.
Also der gemessenen infizierten.
Genau ja wir reden sowieso immer nur von gemessenen zahlen die gesamtzahl der infizierten und da sind wir jetzt auf
über siebzehn tage runter.
Und die kanzlerin hatte mal versehentlich glaube ich gesagt.
Die zeit müsste über.
Über zehn tage ansteigen bevor man nachdenken könnte über irgendwelche lockerungen da
sind wir längst schon bei siebzehn tagen aber sie hat dann glaube ich dann sehr schnell hinterher geschickt ne die zehn tage war nicht so gemeint so und,
interessanter ist aber die netto produktionsraum also,
die sagt an wie viel ein infizierten im durchschnitt wie viele andere der ansteckt und solange diese zahl über eins ist,
werden es mehr so ist die zahl unter eins nimmt die zahl der infizierten und infektiösen,
langsam ab und je weiter die zahl unter eins ist umso schneller geht es halt
zurück die die zahlen.
Da sind wir jetzt auch nach meinen berechnungen unter eins gefallen vor
ja ich glaube am samstag oder freitag hat christian trosten und die regierung haben gesagt okay die nature produktionszeit ist jetzt
um einen herum und es deckte sich dann auch mit meinen berechnungen weil ich dazu sagen muss es ja die von niemandem geprüft sind kein peer-review.
Aber wie gesagt hatte die gleichen ergebnisse
für vor ein paar tagen wie offiziell gemeldet wurden und jetzt werfen meine rechnungen aus dass wir etwa bei null komma acht fünf sind das heißt so im moment ein infizierten steckt,
null komma acht fünf infizierte an wobei wir natürlich sehen müssen dass unsere zahlen wiederum,
uns nur sagen was vor etwa zehn tagen war das heißt wir können jetzt sagen okay vor zehn tagen hat ein infizierten noch null komma acht fünf andere im schnitt angesteckt,
und das heißt wir können jetzt
wir haben die wände beim zuwachs an täglich neu infizierten bei den täglichen todesfällen.
Möglicherweise das hängt noch ein bisschen hinterher vielleicht haben wir es da heute erreicht also ich hatte gesagt
gestern rechnet irgendwie in den nächsten vier tagen spätestens müsste auch eigentlich die wende bei den todesfällen hoffentlich kommen und
die es wiederum relativ da lässt sich halt ganz gut raus sehen wie die belegung
der krankenhausbetten wiederum aussieht weil
man ungefähr weiß dass ein recht hoher prozentsatz derer die intensiv behandelt werden müssen eben auch sterben das heißt die,
ein großteil davon war eben auf einer intensiv station und weil die zahlen das halt.
Von vor ein zwei wochen dass das ganze widerspiegeln wissen wir zumindest dass wir jetzt nicht zigtausend menschen in intensivbehandlung haben sondern
wahrscheinlich eher so die letzte zeit ich weiß sind zweieinhalbtausend patienten.
Das ist aber auch eine zahl die wiederum fünf tage alt ist und da kann sich natürlich sehr sehr schnell ändern da ich aber noch nichts von einer katastrophe gehört habe könnte es auch sein
dass wir auch langsam die wände bei den krankenhausbetten erreichen könnten so oder vielleicht sogar erreicht haben.
An dieser stelle muss ich nochmal nachtragen weil habe ich leider vergessen zu sagen wollte ich tun das datum heute unser heute während wir hier aufnehmen ist der achte april mittwoch der achte april.
Darauf bezieht sich jetzt dein heute gestern und vor zehn tagen dass die daten sozusagen zehn tage hinterherhinken hat damit zu tun dass.
Die operationszeit.
Bis sozusagen das ganze als symptome ausbrechen etcetera und leute dann auch getestet werden entsprechend dauert und deswegen hinkt eben diese zahl hinterher.
Genau man kann sagen dass die leute im schnitt nach fünf tagen es merken dass sie infiziert sind manche früher manche später über fünf tage ist so die annahme dann vielleicht an tag sechs oder sieben,
ihren test kriegen und es dann noch ein zwei tage drei tage braucht bis der test.
Erfolgt ist und die rückmeldung in die offizielle statistik eingeht und da wissen wir liegt es so bei zehn tagen in manchen fällen.
Dauert's ein bisschen länger werden auch vierzehn tage schon gesehen als wir ein bisschen stau hatten so ja das ist der punkt.
Bei anderen dingen etwa bei der zahl der todesfälle läuft es natürlich noch weiter hinterher weil.
Die menschen so im schnitt nach erst siebzehn bis zwanzig tage nach der erkrankung eigentlich sterben
wobei ich eigentlich nur ungefähr drei vier tage teilweise gesehen habe zwischen höhepunkt
infizierten zahl und höhepunkt gemeldete zahl der der toten aber sie.
Läuft definitiv hinterher und während die zahl der jetzt menschen die in krankenhäusern also die,
gehen so im schnitt glaube ich nach dem am siebten tag ins krankenhaus müsste also ungefähr mit den melde zahlen halt korrelieren beziehungsweise müsste man eigentlich sogar ein zwei tage früher
in den krankenhäusern feststellen dass weniger leute kommt bevor die
gemeldeten infektionsbad zahlen von vor zehn tagen zurückgehen also kompliziertes zeit hin und her rechnen und es ja aber so ist es halt.
Was natürlich auch erklärt warum die allgemeinen reflexion über diese zahlen auch zurückhaltend sind also man kann jetzt halt alles mögliche messen und lesen aber,
einfach weil in allem eine gewisse trägheit drinsteckt und das ganze auch noch verbunden ist mit fortlaufend erneuerten wissen über was
jetzt diese krankheit eigentlich wirklich macht wie die fälle verlaufen etcetera dementsprechend halten sich da alle zurück und das auch aus gutem grund.
Plus eben dazu hatten wir auch schon erwähnt die wöchentlichen schwankungen.
Die sich so in den zahlen einstellen und ich habe da auch mal versucht das.
Ja zu quantifizieren wann denn sagen die an welchen wochentagen den meldungen dazu tendieren höher zu sein und niedriger zu sein und wie viel und.
Da kann man sagen das ist ein bisschen nicht intuitiv weil wir bisher immer angenommen hatten dass die zahlen so am wochenende eigentlich einbrechen.
Aber.
Die statistik für die letzten fünf wochen reporting sagt da etwas anderes.
Nämlich dass die sonntags zahlen.
Am am höchsten ne die samstags zahlen sozusagen die zahlen von samstag höher liegen.
In der woche also sozusagen höher überall meiner kurve und die zahlen für mittwochs am niedrigsten unter der kurve so was ja.
Ich recht interessant finde eine genaue erklärung dafür habe ich nicht wie das zustande kommt aber es gibt eben diesen doch signifikanten,
rythmus wobei wenn man das sich das in prozent zahlen anschaut ist es dann wiederum nicht ganz so super viel wie man denken könnte da sind es im schnitt,
dann so um die fünf prozent maximal abweichung nach oben oder oder unten am besten
schlechtesten wochentag.
Könnt ihr das einfach was mit mit diesen melde dynamiken zu tun haben.
Wahrscheinlich also wann wann die leute ins krankenhaus gehen manche gehen vielleicht eher tendieren vielleicht eher am wochenende oder am wochenende nicht zu gehen dann natürlich wann tests irgendwie auch
bearbeitet werden wann die wie lange die gesundheitsämtern brauchen und und so also,
wird's vielleicht irgendwann auseinander dröseln können aber wie gesagt so hinweis ist mittwochs nummern sind.
Zu optimistisch samstags nummern zu pessimistisch in.
Das kann man so sagen und die tage dazwischen wechselt montags nummern sind interessanterweise am genauestens.
Also weichen am wenigsten ab.
Obwohl es eigentlich letztes mal noch die vermutung geäußert hat dass durch diese nachmeldung vom wochenende genau da die verzerrungen entstehen.
Genau
aber das war dann eher etwas so beim ersten hinblick was auch viele leute dann wurde auch in der presse so geschrieben aber jetzt wenn man sich die zahlen tatsächlich anguckt sind's andere tage als.
Was man so beim beim hinschauen oder von ein zwei werten die aus der reihe fallen man dachte.
Das wäre.
Jetzt könnte man ja auch nochmal auf die anderen länder schauen.
Bevor wir da vielleicht auch nochmal drüber reden was was ich aus diesem ganzen zahlenmaterial für uns so konkret ergeben könnte.
Jetzt es gibt ja so verschiedene länder also ich habe also ich habe mangels jetzt einer anderen leichten übersicht in dieser johns
hopkins in diesem corona wahres ressourcen- etwas rum geklickt das ist ja im prinzip eigentlich die einzige wirkliche vergleichsweise einfach zugängliche datenquelle wo man mal schauen kann okay wie geht's denn,
der welt ne standard disclaimer an dieser stelle wird ja auch schon viel diskutiert,
im gegensatz zu den daten mit denen du ja arbeitest die ja wirklich die,
offiziell gemeldeten zahlen sind
holen sich halt diese leute von diesem von dieser forschungsabteilung an dieser johns hopkins universität die daten aus allen möglichen quellen aus medien aus webseiten keine ahnung man weiß es nicht genau,
die wissen's wahrscheinlich genau aber es ist sozusagen.
Quellen unterschiedlicher güte nichtsdestotrotz kann man glaube ich feststellen selbst wenn die jetzt so einzeln nicht stimmen und welche zahl stimmt schon genau.
Den trend den man dann auch an den offiziellen zahlen später ablesen kann sagen die in gewisser hinsicht auch ganz gut voraus also so.
Mal daumen kann man dem glaube ich schon etwas entnehmen und daraus lässt sich natürlich jetzt vor allem erstmal sehen die situation wie hier auch schon vermutet wurde in den usa ist ziemlich krass.
Also extrem viele fälle in diesem moment wenn ich drauf klicke mal bei vierhunderttausend bestätigten infektionen.
Dunkelziffer nochmal eine ganz andere geschichte klar immer auch bei uns und die kurve zeigt halt einfach nochmal gladenbach los.
Nach oben wobei man dann eben glaube ich so diese unterschiede zwischen dem einen und dem anderen tag aus den vorher schon genannten gründen so ein bisschen relativieren muss aber bisher ist da an abschwächung noch nicht so sehr viel zu sehen.
Der zweite krasse fall ist halt spanien.
Da ging's ja auch richtig zur sache und die einschränkungen im öffentlichen leben sind ja auch glaube ich.
Mit italien zusammen am am besten da ist zumindest schon mal eine verlangt verlangsamung zu sehen.
Der infektionen der neuinfektionen zahlen genauso in italien.
Das ist jetzt auch mehrfach berichtet worden dass die zwar immer noch völlig überfordert sind mit allem aber dass einfach die maßnahmen hier schon extrem greifen da sind also die zahlen in den letzten tagen doch signifikant zurückgegangen.
Und ich glaube die haben jetzt auch das erste mal mehr.
Gesundet als neuinfektionen was ja auch nochmal ein ganz interessanter scheitelpunkt ist in dieser ganzen geschichte weil es wird ja oft
bisschen rausgelassen ne so dieses wie viele leute sind wieder gesund geworden klar da kann man dann so eine todes quote ab
zählen aber das bedeutet ja auch leute kommen aus den krankenhäusern raus haben es überstanden machen betten frei et cetera und das hat natürlich dann die gesamtsituation nochmal.
Extrem dann folgt.
Frankreich da finde ich das zahlenmaterial extrem verwirrend weil's da riesige sprünge gegeben hat das mag auch was mit nachmeldungen zu tun gehabt haben aber da steigt auf jeden fall das thermometer noch.
Extrem und auch die kurve von deutschland naja ist recht steil aber auch da.
Eben doch wie schon berichtet überschaubare anstiege.
Und um das vielleicht kurz abzuschließen auch united kingdom sieht überhaupt nicht gut aus also die briten scheint sich da.
Doch sehr schwer zu tun und haben ja auch ihre einschränkungen in der öffentlichkeit relativ spät gestartet und das scheint sich jetzt so ein bisschen zu rechnen zwei länder vielleicht noch.
Weil die uns ja in gewisser hinsicht doppelt betreffen einer also österreich und die schweiz
nicht nur weil es jetzt direkt an deutschland angrenzt aber ist ja auch so ein bisschen die pufferzone sind zwischen italien und deutschland dementsprechend waren diese länder ja auch extrem
betroffen in österreich waren die maßnahmen dann auch relativ krass angezogen worden auch da ist ja von der verlangsamung deutlich was zu sehen und gibt ja jetzt auch schon so erster diskussion in der öffentlichkeit
ankündigungen auch schon dass man in einer woche oder so gedenkt die allgemeinen maßnahmen wieder ein bisschen zurückzufahren ob das eine gute idee ist kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Aber auch die schweiz scheint doch wenn auch medial nicht ganz so beleuchtet hier erfolge zu erzielen.
Warum erzähle ich das jetzt alles auf es ist halt insofern interessant als das ja.
Alle all das jetzt so länder sind wo die maßnahmen jetzt stark angezogen sind so stark es eben geht also usa kann man vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen rausnehmen weil das ändert sich dann auch eben stark von
bundesstaat zu bundesstaat und ich habe irgendwie so ein bisschen das gefühl da wird's noch
richtig schlimm werden aber dann gibt's ja noch diesen sonderfall nämlich schweden.
Ich weiß nicht ob du das beobachtet hast aber in schweden war er lange lange zeit so dieses ach.
Wir machen mal hier weiter mit unserem öffentlichen leben und wir halten mal ein bisschen mehr abstand und das wird schon irgendwie aber dass die strategie scheint jetzt nicht aufzugehen wenn man sich die zahlen anschaut.
Kann ich.
Alles im wesentlichen bestätigen schweden bis gerade so in so einer kurve.
Drin wo es wo es jetzt plötzlich doch höher geht bei den usa muss man vielleicht auch noch sagen relativieren ja.
Das sieht ziemlich heftig aus aber auch da verlangsamt sich das wachstum bereits das trifft aber das passiert fast überall also in dem moment wo.
Halt das ganze auch in die presse kommt selbst wenn man keine maßnahmen ankündigt gibt es schon einen effekt in dem moment wo allein die leute wissen da ist was draußen und den kann man halt auch in den usa.
Sehen das ist halt ein bisschen langsamer also nicht mehr ungebremst ansteigt aber immer noch ja.
Sind die sind noch ziemlich fix unterwegs muss man sagen während österreich tatsächlich uns ein bisschen voraus ist auch in der kurve italien wie du auch richtig gesagt hast also bei italien.
Ist vielleicht noch das interessante zu sagen die veröffentlichen ja auch wie viele.
Fälle jeden tag in intensivbehandlung sind und wie viele überhaupt gerade in behandlung sind.
Und da kann man sehen dass in italien auch dort bei der zahl der behandelten.
Und bei der bei den intensiv plätzen der höhepunkt überschritten ist was halt ja also auch dort.
Sagen geht die belastung für das gesundheitssystem jetzt langsam runter das wird zwar noch wochen dauern.
Zahlen sagen so das allerdings sich in zwei bis drei wochen dort also nachdem er zwei bis drei wochen nach dem höhepunkt.
Auf die hälfte gefallen sein müsste und mal so eine größenordnung zu nennen wie schnell sich entspannt.
Aber es hat natürlich einen ziemlich langen schwanz dann noch am ende also es werden sich.
Auch noch leute weiter anstecken in zwei drei oder vier wochen aber die zahlen.
Dann halt sehr sehr viel kleiner sein und vielleicht noch china.
Da wurde auch immer viel über die zahlen geredet können die überhaupt stimmen ist das so china meldet jetzt pro tag noch so zwei bis drei neu infizierte.
Also da soweit runter sind die klar.
Da gibt's noch irgendwie eine rate so aber die sind halt ziemlich krass auf die bremse gegangen ich habe mir gesagt mal wenn man sich dann die reproduktion zahl kurve anguckt.
Und die vergleich kann man so ein bisschen sehen ja wie heftig.
Die einzelnen länder in die bremse gegangen sind wenn man wenn man so will und china ja die haben die waren halt ziemlich kompromisslos und da.
Ist die rate jetzt eher so dass so im ihre produktionsraum laut offiziellen zahlen bei.
Vielleicht zehn bis zwanzig prozent liegt also sozusagen nur jeder zehnte bis zwanzigsten infizierte im moment schafft es einen weiteren dort gerade anzustecken das sagen jedenfalls die zahlen.
Soweit man es nachvollziehen kann während bei uns beziehungsweise vor zehn tagen war es so bei uns ist es so dass vor zehn tagen eben.
Noch zehn infizierte acht weitere angesteckt haben sowas war auch.
Schon weniger ist aber doch die verlangsamung einfach nicht nicht so schnell vonstatten läuft und bei uns wird es so sieht es aus jedenfalls die kurve bewegt sich irgendwo auf.
Auf den faktor null komma fünf zu also.
Es heißt ja zehn infizierte werden stecken bei uns im moment höchstens fünf leute neu an so was.
Auch dazu führt dass sich das tod läuft wenn wir das lange genug beibehalten.
Tod läuft im sinne von also nicht im sinne von wird komplett verschwinden aber wird zumindest den druck aus dem gesundheitssystem rausnehmen so richtig auszurotten ist ist dieser virus offensichtlich ja nicht mehr.
Ja also der punkt ist äh sagen dass wir an dem punkt wo wir dann wiederum sag mal einstellige infizierten zahlen also gemeldete infizierten zahlen haben wir dann wiederum,
tracking machen können dann sind wir wieder in der lage waren gezielt.
Alle kontakte von irgendeinem infizierten oder möglichst viele kontakte von jemandem der infiziert ist dann auch unter quarantäne
zu stellen und das auf diese art und weise zu versuchen wieder im griff zu behalten wie wir das idealerweise auch vor
zwei monaten gemacht hätten weil wohin uns das ja jetzt zurückbringt dieser shutdown ist in die situation was die zahlen angeht wo wir uns eigentlich schon mal vor zwei monaten befunden haben
und wenn wir halt genauso wie du wieder weitermachen wenn wir also alles aufmachen dann.
Aber schnell wieder an derselben situation.
Sind wir genau in zwei monaten wieder an derselben situation was natürlich nicht passieren wird aber so sieht's aus.
Lass uns doch mal kurz auf united kingdom eingehen als land was du jetzt nicht aufgegriffen hattest.
Wie bei den usa habe ich da halt so ein bisschen meine meine bedenken wie sich das so entwickeln wird jetzt mal gar nicht mal nur so auf basis des zahlen materials sondern eben auch.
Hast du auch schon anfangs erwähnt so wo wir auch so ein land haben was einfach unser unter so einem extremen polarisierung leidet und so ein bisschen.
Sich nicht einig ist so im allgemeinen und wo dann eben maßnahmen nicht einfach durchgezogen werden weil alle eingesehen haben jetzt ist notstand sondern wo einfach.
Noch sehr viel mediale und politische debatte dabei ist was sind nun so der richtige weg ist weil die sich halt alle nicht mehr so richtig über den weg trauen.
Spitze der entwicklung ist natürlich jetzt die tatsache dass.
Boris johnson der premierminister selber ins krankenhaus eingeliefert wurde dort auf der intensivstation liegt mit sauerstoff versorgt wird von.
Wurde explizit gesagt er würde nicht beatmet werden,
gut also im sinne von er ist noch nicht intubiert also man hat ihm noch nicht einen schlauch in die lunge geschoben und und und und und für die beatmung für ihn durch sondern er wird nur mit sauerstoff unterstützt.
Trotzdem klingt das nicht gut.
Das klingt nicht gut und man wünscht auch niemanden sowas auch boris johnson nicht ist ja so mein alter so insofern.
Ja ist das natürlich bedenklich
und die andere sache ist natürlich dass er ja nicht nur boris johnson der die privatperson ist sondern wenn jetzt ein staatsoberhaupt dort der krankheit erliegen sollte
oder innerlich dazu überhaupt aber regierungschef
dann ist das natürlich auch ein ziemlich krasses signal das könnte die information dass er erkrankt ist vielleicht auch dazu führen alleine schon dass das jetzt ernster genommen,
wird und dass man sich vielleicht dann doch mehr an einem strang zieht weil die zahlen sehen in der tat nicht gut ausgehend zwar auch,
also flacht sich zwar auch langsam ab aber die sind noch in einem doch deutlich früheren teil der kurve also noch hinter uns her und ja werden wir sehen wie schnell sie es jetzt zum zum stoppen kriegen.
Auf jeden fall kann man sehen dass eine strategie mit dem infektionsrisiko umzugehen nicht sonderlich klug zu sein zu sein scheint so nicht klug gewesen ist.
Am ende also wir werden es am ende glaube ich es ist noch zu zu früh um da jetzt wirklich genau zu sagen wie viel schlimmer.
Es am ende eigentlich sein wird.
Vielleicht noch ein paar zahlen zum sagen frage wo liegen die limits unseres gesundheitssystems und.
Wir haben derzeit auch gerne offizielle zahlen zur so gut ich das recherchieren konnte,
auch aus dem intensiv register verzeichnis was es jetzt gibt dieses diva scheint es so zu sein
dass wir etwa viermal
so viele intensivbetten innerhalb von vierundzwanzig stunden deutschlandweit freimachen können wie derzeit durch corona patienten belegt sind also
wenn es jetzt so zwei zwischen zwei und dreitausend sind die im moment intensiv behandelt werden sagt offiziellen zahlen,
waren dreitausendfünfhundertachtzig die ich die ich gesehen hatte.
Und es sind ungefähr zehntausend freie intensivbetten für in den nächsten vierundzwanzig stunden belegbar so nur um mal so ein gefühl für die relation
zu zu kriegen und immerhin um die wahrscheinlich.
Zehntausend intensivbetten sind aktuell mit anderen patienten belegt.
Mit so also wir haben vier mal so viele andere intensivpatienten wie corona patienten und das ist lang auch dass das ding immer das argument wenn leute kommen naja.
Können wir es nicht laufen lassen so.
Das würde dazu führen dass die zehntausend leute die jetzt gerade intensiv behandelt werden wegen was anderem.
Ernsthafte probleme kriegen das heißt dann fangen die leute an auch an anderen dingen zu sterben und nicht an korona weil sie einfach nicht behandelt werden können sodass es sagen das problem und.
Scheinen wir so sieht's aus jetzt wahrscheinlich gemeistert zu haben also unser gesundheitssystem
zeigt keine anzeichen von zusammenbruch was man aber auch sagen muss das ist nur die deutschlandweite betrachtung in einzelnen krankenhäusern und in einzelnen gegenden.
Kann es ganz anders aussehen man kann das eben nicht ohne weiteres einfach sagen wir verteilen die patienten weil das ist schwierig und.
Teuer und aufwendig intensivpatienten zu verlegen habe ich,
gehört die müssen vorbereitet werden da ist ein ganzes team.
Damit beschäftigt dann müssen die transportmittel anschließend desinfiziert werden und so das heißt auch jeder transport bindet einfach kapazität man kann also nicht einfach.
Leute hin und her wegen.
Wie man lustig ist so dass es halt in einzelnen gegen den hotspots wohl nach wie vor auf hundert prozent läuft und auch die benachbarten krankenhäuser schon,
ganz eng sind aber sieht man guckt man sich die die karte an im moment sieht es so aus dass es doch noch,
fast überall in reichweite einmal noch freie intensivbetten gibt das zumindest sind die informationen die mir zugänglich sind.
Teilweise ist es ja auch so dass bestimmte krank krankenhäuser dann dedizierte für eine region die korona patienten aufnehmen und dass eben leute die nicht von corona betroffen sind dann eben.
Andere krankenhäuser aufsuchen die sie dann wiederum voll auf alle anderen fälle konzentrieren weil es ja auch dann teilweise problematisch ist dass in einem,
gebäude zu halten nicht jedes krankenhaus hat halt intensivstation mit verschiedenen etagen oder komplett separaten
bereichen wo man das eben so ohne weiteres trennen könnte und das ganze was da noch mit dran hängt ist natürlich auch die belastung des gesundheitssystems selber und natürlich der leute die dort arbeiten,
dass die eben auch selber akut.
Natürlich von infektionen bedroht sind insbesondere solange die ganze ausstattung mit schutzausrüstung mundschutz etcetera immer noch so hinterher läuft.
Das ist auch der grund warum ich jetzt bei dem vereinigten königreich ein wenig skeptisch bin.
Das auch gerne so zum ausdruck bringen weil gerade dieser national health service.
Ja so ein bisschen so die ikone auch des gesellschaft systems dort ist ja nun schon allein durch den brexit enorm.
Unter druck geraten weil ihnen einfach so viele mitarbeiter und da war der anteil sehr groß.
Die aus der eu kam halt einfach abgewandert sind in den letzten jahren weil die gesagt haben dass mich in dem scheiß alleine ich gehe jetzt wieder zurück in mailand werdet schon sehen was er davon habt.
Und dadurch dass ich jetzt eben auch die,
leute selber nicht beschützen können die sie da haben haben die halt auch relativ hohe fallzahlen im personal also die sind halt auch schon viele doktoren etcetera weggestorben und das belastet natürlich das system nochmal zusätzlich.
Zudem fakt dass sie eben auch deutlich weniger intensiv betten und kapazität haben als deutschland.
Also vielleicht nochmal dazu wie gesagt bei uns sieht so aus als wenn wir sagen in der spitze irgendwo zehn bis zwanzig prozent der kapazität unseres gesundheitssystems,
durch korona beansprucht worden sein wird das ist.
Ungefähr die größenordnung die normalerweise auch an freien kapazitäten da ist wir haben so neu zwischen achtzig und neunzig prozent sind die krankenhäuser normalerweise aus
belastet das heißt so größenordnungsmäßigen hammer quasi
gerade noch die kurve hingekriegt durch spezielle maßnahmen wurden halt.
Viermal so viele betten frei und verfügbar gemacht wie normalerweise frei und verfügbar sind sodass wir sagen in die reserve eigentlich gar nicht rein mussten bis bisher so,
landesweit betrachtet aber.
Bei verdopplung daten die wir hatten die bei zwei zwischen zwei und vier tagen lagen könnte man sagen okay wenn wir jetzt diese maßnahmen jetzt nur,
eine woche später eingeführt hätten so dann wäre es richtig eng geworden und sagen zwei stunden zwei wochen später die maßnahmen einzuführen
hätte halt zum zusammenbruch geführt das kann man jetzt sagen also es ist nicht so dass.
Das jetzt super bequem war dass wir eigentlich hätten noch uns ein bisschen länger entspannen können sondern das war schon.
Höchste zeit höchste.
War höchste zeit war höchste zeit das kann man sagen.
Und ich hoffe es kommen auch nicht irgendwelche überraschungen jetzt noch bei den bei den zahlen und ich mache mich hier gerade zum obst aber das ist das was hier die zahlen so sagen
das ja wahrscheinlich demnächst die ersten ankommen werden sozusagen auch das war doch alles gar nicht so schlimm was habt ihr denn alle alle für eine panik gemacht.
Die diskussion werden wir auf jeden fall kriegen und haben wir auch teilweise schon aber das lässt sich wahrscheinlich kaum vermeiden.
Es gab ja jetzt nicht nur neue zahlen sondern es gab ja auch eine ganze reihe neuer interessanter,
die jetzt rund um die ganze korona pandemien herausgekommen sind und neue beachtung gefunden haben zu unterschiedlichen dingen du hast ja auch einiges.
Angeschaut insbesondere was so die infektionsweg e betrifft oder.
Ja mein auslöser war halt in dieser.
Ja doktor strick der die heinzberg patienten so eines der ersten großen kluster in nordrhein-westfalen
der dem nachgegangen ist dort und auch von haushalt zu haushalt gegangen ist abstriche gemacht hat von allen möglichen objekten in haushalten von infizierten und geguckt hat
wo findet sich denn eigentlich wieviel virus so auf welchen gegenständen möbeln auf dem boden auf lichtschalter auf handys mit so
die konnten es zwar in diesen haushalten überall virus material nachweisen in.
In diesem jahr auf den gegenständen aber konnten kein nichts von diesem material was sie irgendwo abgenommen haben.
Anzüchten in zell kultur so das heißt die viren die sie dort gefunden haben waren quasi tot.
Oder nicht nicht mehr infektiös meldet sich keiner dran anstecken können so deswegen ist halt der doktor strick auch im fernsehen irgendwo vorgeprescht.
So ja.
Es gibt keine ansteckung über gegenstände so und da wollte ich dann wissen okay ist das so wie sieht es so aus und wenn man dann auf die seiten vom guckt,
ist dort auch im prinzip.
Wird tröpfchen infektion steht halt ganz ganz vorne so und auch christian rosten sagte in einem seiner podcast.
Das ältere untersuchungen jetzt nicht zu korona gezeigt haben dass wahrscheinlich bei krankheiten dieser art so maximal zehn prozent.
Schmierige infektion stattfindet oder übertragung über gegenstände.
Aber möglicherweise auch null prozent also irgendwo zwischen null und zehn prozent liegt die wahrheit und das gilt halt jetzt nicht unbedingt für spezielle situation wie kliniken wo man es dann mit.
Viel material vielleicht zu
tun hat so wo das dann doch eine rolle spielt aber so im normalen alltagsleben so an irgendwelchen türgriffen oder
an irgendwelchen gegenständen sich zu infizieren ist sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich da muss dann vor ihm jemand drauf gehostet haben oder das abgeleckt haben oder sowas so ansonsten.
Passiert es wahrscheinlich so gut wie gar nicht so also tröpfcheninfektion.
So dann habe ich ihn gefragt okay was ist denn jetzt ganz praktisch eigentlich wie kann ich mir denn so eine tröpfcheninfektion eigentlich vorstellen und habe mir dein studium.
Dazu rausgesucht und es ist so dass.
Beim niesen und husten wissen wir natürlich tröpfchen freigesetzt werden aber was.
Dass wir auch wissen beim sprechen wenn wir alle kennen leute mit feuchter aussprache wo einem dann irgendwie mal tröpfchen ins auge fliegen.
Und selbst beim normalen atmen,
werden partikel freigesetzt einfach dadurch dass luft über bestimmte lungenbläschen streicht oder irgendwelche unebenheiten und dort halt auch ganz feinste.
Partikel mitreißt und man kann natürlich davon ausgehen dass je heftiger ich atme also beim sport oder.
Beim sprechen ihr lauter und heftiger ich spreche umso mehr partikel komm da raus und beim normalen sprechen sind die sagen die studien sind zu zehn partikel pro sekunde beim husten sind's dreitausend.
Und beim nächsten bis zu vierzigtausend partikel die da frei oder ja tröpfchen die da freigesetzt werden.
Und diese tröpfchen sind so im allgemeinen ja zwischen null komma eins und zehn mikrometer groß also millionstel meter unsichtbar im prinzip.
Hundert mikrometer werden null komma ein millimeter also.
Sagen ein zehntel von null komma eins millimeter also zehn mal kleiner als man es eigentlich sehen kann und.
Diese tröpfchen haben jetzt in interessante eigenschaften nämlich so irgendwo zwischen drei und sechs mikrometer
liegt so die grenze wo wenn die tröpfchen kleiner sind das zum soul wird also sie sich in der luft lösen und nicht mehr ohne weiteres.
Runterfallen sondern halt schweben können die ganz klein über drei bis sechs mikrometer ist es so dass sie dann,
relativ schnell anfangen so zu boden zu fallen und sie sind nicht in der luft halten sondern ja die gravitation die aus der luft rauszieht und die eben auf den boden fallen jetzt ist es aber außerdem so je kleiner
so ein tröpfchen ist umso weniger virus kopien kann es natürlich enthalten logisch nach konzentrieren.
Bei gleicher konzentration und wenn man da mal so rechnet ist bei den ganz kleinen tropfen die.
Halt zum soul werden also unter drei mikro metern,
sind selbst bei den patienten die sehr hohe virus konzentration aufweisen zumindest die habe ich mir mal die höchsten die in den studien.
Gemessen wurden rausgegriffen bei denen.
Ist es so dass bei einem ein mikrometer tropfen statistisch nur jeder zwanzigste tropfen überhaupt einen virus partikel enthalten kann.
Jetzt ist es so ja theoretisch reicht auch ein virus partikel um sich zu infizieren aber die wahrscheinlichkeit dass ein dieser eine virus partikel erreicht und dann eine erfolgreiche infektion erreicht er muss halt.
An der richtigen stelle im körper landen und selbst dann das sind halt chemisch molekulare vorgänge die alle nur mit einer bestimmten wahrscheinlichkeit stattfinden das heißt selbst selbst dann.
Gibt es nur eine restwasser zeit von ein paar prozent also wenn ich so einen tropfen einatme oder wenn ich ein virus partikel einatmen.
Ist es wahrscheinlich eher so im einstelligen prozentbereich dass dieser virus partikel mich auch erfolgreich infizieren kann so ich brauche also schon in der regel eine deutliche ladung damit ich mich infiziere.
Es ist so und wie gesagt je größer die tropfen
umso schneller fallen sie zu boden und je kleiner die tropfen kommt dann noch ein anderer effekt die verdunsten nämlich sehr schnell an der luft ich meine das ist wie in den vergaser letztlich dann nutzen wir das das kleine tröpfchen sehr schnell verdunsten.
Sondern ein mikrometer tropfen ist wenn es sich wenn er aus reinem wasser besteht ist er in sekundenbruchteilen in.
Zwei zehntel sekunden verdunstet und verdunstung wenn da jetzt virus partikel drin sind.
Da sind ja jetzt auch salzige gelöst zum beispiel im speichel oder in der körperflüssigkeit und beim verdunsten fängt natürlich die an die an die konzentration zu steigen so es bilden sich
kristalle unter umständen salzkristalle da drin und das alles ist nicht gut für den virus so das kann halt und dürfte wahrscheinlich sagen allein schon eine ganze menge auch wiederum der viren,
gleich killen das sagen einfach verdunsten des millionen nicht gut ist studien sagen aber dass es tröpfchen gibt wo.
Das virus wenn die nicht zu klein und nicht zu groß sind dass sie dann das virus mehrere minuten infektiös bleiben kann.
Und da kommen wir dann lang zu einer situation.
Wo sagt im normalfall wenn man sich so vorstellen jemand läuft rum redet.
Und wenn man sich jetzt so vorstellt die tropfen tröpfchen würden leuchten würden da jetzt so zehn
kleine leuchtende partikel rauskommen würden quasi verdampfen oder verglühen oder zu boden fallen so und werden halt normalerweise ganz schnell weg und
harmlos und kommen auch nicht weit das ist dann die normale situation aber.
Wer jetzt die luftfeuchtigkeit richtig stimmt und entsprechende luft bewegung da ist und die temperatur und so passt scheint es so zu sein.
Das ist jetzt nicht ja da gibt es auch studien die das bestätigen allerdings nicht.
Jetzt konkreten ansteckung aber da ist es dann so dass lang tröpfchen in der luft.
Weder schnell genug runterfallen noch irgendwie schnell genug durch verdunsten wirksam gemacht werden sondern sich quasi in der luft halten für eine weile und dann.
Auch entsprechend weit wandern können dann helfen so die anderthalb oder zwei meter einfach nicht mehr wenn sich die tröpfchen im ganzen raum verbreiten und dann sagen.
Die krankheit ausnahmsweise sagen airborne wird also durch die luft übertragbar,
letztlich nur betonen normalerweise ist nicht so bei krankheiten die durch die luft übertragbar sind kann es sein dass ich mich da draußen auf dem flur anstecken oder im fahrstuhl wenn vorher dort ein infizierte gefahren
drin ist das ist normalerweise nicht der fall bei korona aber.
Anders lassen sich jetzt so ansteckungseffekte sogenannte super spreding nicht gut erklären.
Und wir hatten verschiedene super spreding events also der club trompete in berlin da haben sich zweiundvierzig von siebzig leuten infiziert an einem abend da fragt man sich dann okay da war jetzt ein.
Infiziert dadrunter soweit wir wissen und wie kann der jetzt.
Zweiundvierzig von den leuten in dem laden anstecken hat jetzt zweiundvierzig leute abgeknutscht ist er von einem zum anderen gegangen sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Sondern was passiert ist ist dass der vielleicht laut gesprochen hat vielleicht auch getanzt wurde dass die bedingungen richtig waren und sagen der ganze raum mit virus partikeln oder ein großteil des raums mit
virus partikeln gefüllt war und sich so die leute infiziert haben oder anderes beispiel chor in den usa die haben eine chorprobe gemacht.
Da haben sich fünfundvierzig von sechzig leuten bei der chorprobe infiziert,
gut kann man sagen okay vielleicht hat irgendwie hat der infizierte irgendwas mitgebracht was alle gegessen haben aber das konnte jetzt nicht festgestellt werden sondern sehr wahrscheinlich lag es daran singen.
Passt halt zu der these so.
Wenn ich laut spreche oder das gerade beim singen das dann man wahrscheinlich deutlich mehr tröpfchen freisetzt und das so die eine person ist geschafft hat.
Zweiundvierzig leute zu infizieren durch singen fünfundvierzig durchsingen,
und es würde natürlich sehr gut passen zu anderen dingen wie in den im skiurlaub.
Après-ski die infektion beim
bei karnevalssitzung die wir gesehen haben wo ganz viele leute sich infiziert haben das fußballspiel in italien was verdächtigt wird so eine so ein super spreding event gewesen zu sein oder die sekte in.
Korea so die machen wo halt ein eine einzelne,
person auf jeden gottesdienst es geschafft hat wie massen an leuten anzustecken und das würde also.
Dann ganz gut.
Passen eigentlich diese theorie rausfinden genau werden wir es wahrscheinlich nie was da in den fällen.
Im einzelnen abgelaufen ist weil das lässt sich dann im nachhinein nicht mehr wirklich.
Nachvollziehen aber ich sowohl,
studien als auch die ganze theorie als auch das ergebnis passen an dieser stelle mal verdammt gut zusammen und das ist insoweit erfreulich weil man da natürlich.
So ein bisschen dann rausziehen kann was sind so die gefährlichen situationen die man selber erstmal auf jeden fall meiden sollte und.
Das sind,
fernsehen ja laut sprechende singende und was wir schon länger wissen nießen und hustende leute aber für mich war das halt sprechen und,
singen war so ein bisschen neu für mich und das ganze halt,
vor allem in geschlossenen räumen aber es gibt auch hinweise gerade bei dem bei dem fußballspiel oder.
Auch bei bestimmten demonstrationen dass das ganze des.
Auch das im freien dann nicht völlig sicher ist das ist aber frei im freien ist sicherlich deutlich sicher also das heißt solchen situationen eben gerade,
mit leuten sprechen sollte man eigentlich,
im moment grundsätzlich nur geschützt oder aus größerer entfernung,
und das sind die das sind die gefahrensituation plus eben größere events in innenräumen wo die leute laut sind so,
oder schnell atmen ja jogger manchmal seit ich das weiß halte ich auch noch ein bisschen mehr abstand zu joggern so ja weil man weiß nie gut.
Auch dazu sagen dass.
Bei der zahl der infizierten natürlich muss man jeden potenziell als infiziert betrachten aber es ist nicht so dass jetzt tatsächlich.
Man wenn einem hundert jogger entgegenkommen
wird wahrscheinlich im moment oder wahrscheinlich von tausend joggern die einem entgegenkommen wenn ein oder zwei infektiös
so das vielleicht auch nochmal zu der quote aber wir wissen halt nicht welche von denen und wenn es genau der ist dann habe ich halt pech gehabt und das sollte halt ja nicht passieren also.
Insofern deshalb habe ich da für mich raus rausgezogen und es bedeutet natürlich auch erstmal nichts gutes.
Ja für großveranstaltungen also großveranstaltungen habe ich nur mit maske.
Und zwar eigentlich auch wahrscheinlich nur mit schutzmasken tatsächlich aber man da kommen wir dann dann vielleicht auch gleich noch zum zum thema masken.
Ja kann man wahrscheinlich mit masken mit geeigneten auch großveranstaltungen machen wäre.
Mal meine vermutung aber meine these aber nicht ohne und ja und letzter punkt noch ja kreuzfahrtschiffe und.
Flugzeugträger scheint auch nicht so oder scheint auch orte zu sein wo man sich eben sehr gut anstecken kann.
Oder u-boote.
Ja
Hatte ich jetzt gott sei dank nichts gebucht in dieser hinsicht aber.
Was man jetzt auch rauslesen kann aus diesen studien und diesen jüngsten jüngeren erkenntnissen ist dass eigentlich die handlungsanweisungen die generell so ausgegeben werden auch ganz gut passen also dieses
abstand halten an sich ist schon mal ein.
Guter punkt und selbst wenn sozusagen diese krassen maßnahmen die wir derzeit haben zurückgefahren werden ist das vermutlich etwas was ich eben noch auf.
Längere sicht zimt diesen abstand einfach beizubehalten.
Weil's einfach alles verlangsamen wird ja es wird es wird noch zu infektionen kommen aber man wird sie eben.
Mindern und zwar nennenswert minder schlechte nachricht ist natürlich wie du schon gesagt hast so fußballspiele und konzerte oder vor allem halt so partys.
Krasse berliner keller klub party ist ja wo man einfach den schweiß.
In der luft sehen kann ja das ist natürlich eine situation wo er sich derzeit überhaupt gar nicht vorstellen kann
wie das überhaupt innerhalb des nächsten jahres noch stattfinden soll ohne dass man
man sich halt zu sehr gefährdet das macht die sache schwieriger wird vielleicht ein bisschen was anderes sein wenn's im freien ist aber auch das ist natürlich
derzeit noch steht das zumindest im raum ob das überhaupt akzeptabel ist für uns.
Ja entsprechend lass uns dann mal doch auf diese masken diskussion kommt da ging es ja dann auch in der öffentlichkeit extrem hin und her mit ist das jetzt eine gute idee das ist keine gute idee sollte man das vorschreiben was passiert dann wenn man das tut
mittlerweile haben viele
leute die vielleicht ein bisschen arbeitsausfall hatten ein neues business entdeckt das heißt nämlich masken nähen und online verkaufen
das finde ich auch ganz super ich habe auch fleißig genäht
nicht nicht um sie zu verkaufen aber den eigenbedarf mal abzustecken und meine alten nähmaschinen künstler auch mal wieder auszuprobieren gute nachricht war kann ich noch,
ist ja immer immer geil da also was man so in der jugend lernt das bleibt lange und das habe ich da auch wieder gemerkt.
Falls du noch eine brauchst also ich könnte die maschine auch nochmal rausholen.
Ja meine hat er gesagt ich müsste mal gucken eigentlich müssten langsam die von meiner cousine aus tschechien angekommen sein bei meinen eltern da
muss ich dann mal nachhaken sehen ja aber danke für das angebot.
Ja zu meinem zu den masken das gab es halt eben auch.
Insbesondere eine sehr interessante studie die jetzt nicht entkommen aber auch korona viren aber andere corona viren.
Betrifft insofern ist die wahrscheinlich übertragbar da wurden,
verschiedene viren also verschiedene erkrankte patienten manche die an corona viren litten andere grippe patienten oder an renovieren also sich schnupfen erkältung.
Den wurden masken aufgesetzt also chirurgen masken.
Also diese hoch wirksame.
Nein nein nein nein nein nein nein chirurgen masken sind eigentlich im prinzip die diese stoff masken.
Also die normale mund nase schutz.
Die sind genau diesen mund nasen schutz ja also diese stoff tücher die also was unter dem stichwort auch op- maske.
Läuft so was eigentlich verhindern soll dass der operateur oder.
Die anderen irgendwie tröpfchen in die offenen wunden spucken so das ist der der sinn und zweck dass sie halt ja den patienten zu schützen nicht den träger,
ähm und was man da festgestellt hat also hat dann jeweils dreißig minuten lang gemessen.
Was die patienten so ausatmen die haben auch so einmal die sie einmal die minute gehustet im schnitt also was sagen aus dem patienten rauskommt mit und ohne so eine maske und.
Da haben sie erstmal festgestellt dass.
Bei den meisten patienten überhaupt gar nichts rauskommt weder mit noch ohne maske also.
Ein großteil der der der patienten waren gar nicht infektiös oder war gar nichts mehr drin in den,
tropfen ein paar bei denen aber wo sie was nachweisen konnten.
So das waren vier patienten nicht je nachdem drei oder vier patienten.
Sie haben halt alle patienten mit und ohne chirurgen maske jeweils für dreißig minuten die luft aufgefangen und
geguckt was ist da drin an kleinen und großen partikeln und wir haben noch nicht mal geguckt ob man die ansichten kann sondern die haben einfach nur einen nachweis gemacht also,
ob da viren drin sind tot oder lebendig und haben interessanterweise gefunden dass leute,
mit maske und corona
dass da auch gar nichts raus kam also sie konnten nicht ein virus in der ausgeatmete luft von corona patienten nachweisen innerhalb von dreißig minuten,
atmen genießen.
Was auch husten da kam nichts raus so bei anderen viren kam aber interessanterweise was raus also sowohl bei grippe viren als auch bei den renovieren konnten sie
bei solchen patienten sehr wohl viren nachweisen die durch die chirurgen würde ich die op maske rausgekommen sind nicht aber corona viren unklar warum weil eigentlich habe dann extra nachgeguckt
das ist die große sind denn jetzt corona viren und im vergleich zu grippevirus aber wir sind ungefähr gleich groß eigentlich
so insofern jetzt was rein mechanisches kannst jetzt nicht sein aber es ist auf jeden fall ein echtes kuriosum sodass man aber auf jeden fall sagen kann
so diese masken schützen verdammt gut
gegen ab sondern von corona wären das sagt die studie und,
wir können jetzt nicht sagen hundert prozent weil wir nur vier patienten dort dort hatten aber das ist sozusagen schon mal positiv wie es jetzt mit selbstgemachten masken im vergleich zu jetzt op- masken aussieht
keine ahnung aber so.
Man kann auch davon ausgehen allein nur nachdem wie so eine tröpfcheninfektion abläuft
das tröpfchen festgehalten werden und das auch das risiko andere zu infizieren extrem reduziert sein sollte man sich wieder nochmal dass das bild vor augen ruft mit den
ist er mal partikeln die da rauskommen mit den leuchtenden wenn ich da halt ein tuch vor packe kann ich mir vorstellen,
da fliegen dann halt keine partikel mehr einfach so.
Raus sondern bleiben halt drin und vergehen dann hoffentlich innerhalb der maske relativ schnell oder was auch immer man auf hat also dieser weg sagen
sieht nach studienlage sehr gut aus so das ist sozusagen die eine richtung.
Die andere richtung wiederum um ansteckung zu vermeiden da sind ja war ja immer diese sogenannten.
Fashion protection pieces das sind diese masken die man die eigentlich dazu dienen eben.
Partikel und ei sohle aus der luft zu filtern sind.
Spezifiziert und getestet auf.
Partikel oder tröpfchen von der größe zwischen drei je nachdem drei und sechs mikrometer weil das,
weil sie für diese partikel größe am durchlässig sind,
für größere oder auch interessanterweise kleinere partikel sind sie weniger durchlässig sind dann verschiedene effekte die zum tragen kommen kleinere partikel werden irgendwie elektrostatisch dann gebunden und.
Festgehalten und größere eben mechanisch die sind halt spezifiziert je nachdem,
f p eins bis drei wie viele partikel sie tatsächlich zurückhaltend die einfachsten masken also selbst die ganz.
Billigen sag mal heimwerker masken die so als grob staub maske man kennt halten.
Immer noch so im schlimmsten fall dreiviertel ab so fünfundzwanzig prozent komm mal durch so kann man sagen okay damit reduziere ich dann theoretisch vielleicht meine ansteckung wahrscheinlichkeit um.
Ein viertel vielleicht und bei.
Den drei masken die sind spezifiziert dass sie im schnitt zwei komma fünf prozent.
Durchlassen das meiste ist einfach weil die nicht dicht anliegen und sagen durch die seite eigentlich so neben strom noch da ist und im schlimmsten fall fünf prozent.
Durchlassen dürfen so aber im durchschnitt eben.
Nur die fünf was bedeutet dass man mit so einer drei maske zwischen zwanzig.
Rund fünfzig mal weniger partikel.
Aufnimmt so was man dann kann man vielleicht nicht eins zu eins umrechnen aber rein statistisch gesehen kann ich mich halt mit so 'ner fdp drei maske.
Im durchschnitt fünfzig mal länger in der infektionsweg situation aufhalten bevor ich krank werde als ohne.
Das heißt und das ist doch schon mal ein wort das so.
Das ist eine zahl.
Das ist doch schon mal so faktor fünfzig und das ist natürlich gerade für medizinisches personal oder für andere in hochrisiko situationen besonders wichtig aber eben wissen.
Eigentlich hätte ich gerne auch eine fdp drei maske wenn ich irgendwie mit jemandem.
Reden muss wenn ich mit jemandem in eine persönliche rede situation komme ich hätte mit so einer maske hätte ich jetzt.
Eher weniger probleme oder angst davor auch mal ein gespräch zu führen wenn.
In einem geschlossenen raum mit jemandem wo ich da nicht fünf meter weg sitze.
So also insofern können wir halt festhalten masken helfen so.
Das wissen wir ja schon schon länger und helfen auch in beide richtungen kann man sagen aber was.
Man auch.
Mal einige leute wissens oder haben's schon am eigenen leib gemerkt die vielleicht länger mal masken tragen die sind halt nicht nur super unbequem und nervig wobei man sich da ein bisschen dran
gewöhnen kann aber so für zehn zwanzig minuten ist jetzt kein ding oder mal eben aufsetzen so.
Aber wenn man stunden unter seiner maske verbringen muss oder einen ganzen tag das
ist fast unerträglich und deswegen auch nach arbeitsschutz so in deutschland ist es so wenn du mit fp drei mit einer fdp drei maske.
Arbeitest musst du normalerweise ich vorher ärztlich durchchecken lassen so musst du gesund sein
und alle zwei stunden mindestens eine halbe stunde pause machen also die maske für eine halbe stunde abnehmen weil sonst einfach gesundheitsschäden entstehen weil durch den atem widerstand beim ein und beim ausatmen des strapaziert natürlich die lunge
und gerade dann wiederum für leute die jetzt sowieso schon lungen probleme haben,
oder erkrankt sind ist es natürlich ein zusätzliches problem so eine so eine maske insofern sind auch die maßnahmen oder das was sagen die offizielle politik
die ja jetzt gerade auch so beschuldigt wird von masken abgeraten zu haben weil man nicht genug hatte und dann das gesundheitspersonal keine hat wenn dann alle mit masken rumlaufen
ja so masken helfen wäre gut wenn jeder eine hat aber vorzuschreiben dass man sich draußen an der freien luft mit,
maske zu bewegen hat so wie es in manchen ländern auch in tschechien passiert ist ist jetzt rein.
Von den.
Übertragungswagen her ein echter overkill und wieder zusammen mit den möglichen gesundheitsschäden vielleicht auch kontra reduziert aber unterm strich wiederum,
ist das problem dass masken bei uns bislang null akzeptanz hatten also ich kenne leute die halt ja.
Angegangen worden sind weil sie eine maske getragen haben das hat sich wohl hoffentlich ein bisschen geändert aber vielleicht,
wäre nur wenn man für eine woche oder für ein paar tage das ganze angeordnet und dann wieder zurück genommen hätte hätte wenigstens jeder jetzt eine maske und das sozusagen das das stigma wäre durch durchbrochen
so und masken werden dann wahrscheinlich auch das erste also masken pflicht was man dann zumindest unter bestimmten situationen dann wieder lockern könnte aber
für öffentliche verkehrsmittel zum beispiel also ich würde zumindest für eine geraume zeit
öffentliche verkehrsmittel masken pflicht erlassen weil
das sind halt situationen wo man dann wenn da nur einer ist man wieder ruckzuck.
Zehn zwanzig dreißig fünfzig infizierte haben kann und das möchte man doch wirklich soweit es gibt minimieren.
Also insbesondere also besonders enge situation busse straßenbahnen u-bahn da ist es halt richtig krass da hat sich ja auch negativ ausgezahlt
dass bestimmte städte weil weniger nachfrage war dann eben auch das
angebot eingeschränkt haben womit dann die leute die dann wieder genauso eng zusammen gepfercht wurden es wurde teilweise zurückgenommen london war das unter anderem so ich weiß nicht ganz genau wie es auch wieder zurückgenommen haben
kann gerade die situation hier in unserer stadt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht weil ich mich natürlich von diesen orten auch fernhalte.
Ja das ist auf jeden fall ein klares argument für mehr zu fuß gehen mehr mit dem fahrrad fahren
auto ja blöderweise ist natürlich an der stelle auch ein relativ sicherer ort.
Wenn man alleine fährt.
Na klar wenn man alleine fährt oder mit den leuten fährt mit dem man sowieso den ganzen tag in der wohnung zusammenhängt weil da ist es natürlich dann auch nicht zu vermeiden.
Ja zu den öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln so ihr habt ja jetzt zwar keine statistiken so ich weiß es wurde ein bisschen runtergefahren aber was ich einfach so.
Beim beobachten von straßenbahnen sehen konnte und bussen dass die auslastung,
in der praxis extrem gering war also das höchste was ich in der straßenbahn gesehen habe in der kompletten wo eigentlich zweihundert leute reinpassen waren drei leute ich habe etliche straßenbahnen.
Wo nur ein oder zwei leute unterwegs waren und auch bei den bussen drei vier leute in so einem kompletten bus,
viel mehr war da nicht aber es gab auch von situationen gehört zu bestimmten zeiten u-bahn wo es dann doch ein bisschen doch wieder unangenehm eng geworden ist und natürlich in dem moment wo wir wieder hochfahren
wird's natürlich eng werden und also meiner meinung nach öffentliche verkehrsmittel benutzen.
Ohne maske ist ein rezept für eine katastrophe in den nächsten monaten oder woche.
Also sollte man eine haben und sich eine machen und diese ganz normalen stoff masken bringen es einfach ich trag die also wenn ich in laden reingehe oder so weiter jetzt eigentlich immer stelle all allerdings auch fest ich bin.
Nicht der einzige aber auf jeden fall noch einer deutlichen minderheit aber das sind halt auch so eine normalisierung prozesse die müssen erstmal rein sickern deutschland muss sich einfach erstmal trennen im kopf von diesem gedanken mit.
Oder kommt jemand der ist krank was fällt dem einen überhaupt.
In die öffentlichkeit zu gehen aber dass das so ein bisschen die wahrnehmung bisher immer gewesen das deswegen auch diese diese vision die dann teilweise an den tag gelegt worden ist ja auch eine nachvollziehbare reaktion
nur dass eben das signal falsch interpretiert worden und das muss ich halt jetzt ändern von da ist jemand der ist krank mein gott was macht der hier ne weil man denkt so ja wenn eine maske auf hatte ist der ist krank der ist ansteckend warum warum liegt hier nicht im krankenhaus
so stattdessen kauft er hier ein hin zu.
Wir haben es hier mit einer situation zu tun wo man ansteckend ist bevor man auch nur die chance hat zu wissen dass man selber infiziert ist.
Also keiner von uns kann es wissen so man kann es vermuten und,
glauben alles kann man kann man alles machen aber wissen tut man es nicht und wenn ich die zahlen richtig folgt habe ist dieser zeitraum bis man überhaupt wenn überhaupt.
Spürbare symptome bekommt irgendwo bei fünf tagen oder sowas.
In dieser größenordnung das heißt es kann einem passieren dass man fünf tage lang durch die gegend läuft und dann kriegt man erst kratzen im hals,
fieber was auch immer reaktion sind ja von den leuten dann auch sehr unterschiedlich,
und zu dem zeitpunkt ist man dann eben auch schon selber zu so einem super wetter geworden und das gilt es halt zu verhindern das kann man einfach relativ effizient dadurch verhindern dass man einfach so eine blöde stoff maske auf hat die gibt es mittlerweile auch irgendwie,
schon in allen fußballvereins farben und
volles programm also einfach eine ganz neue methode sozusagen jetzt es gibt jetzt nicht nur t-shirts und jacken und mützen sei es gibt es auch.
Ja gewiss
ein gewisser hinsicht sogar noch noch geileres signal sozusagen seine farben in die welt zu tragen als bisher weil leute einmal intuitive in der regel erstmal ins gesicht also in die augen schauen und da kann man dann halt so richtig schön sein fußballvereins logo platzieren funktioniert wunderbar sehe ich auch gerade diesen trend,
läuft ne und das signal ist halt einfach ich weiß es nicht ich habe das jetzt mal auf das für den fall.
Dass ich doch infiziert bin dich.
Nicht anstecken so ist einfach ein dienst an anderen und ich selber merke auch bei mir wie ich halt im wesentlichen leute jetzt so als.
Etwas unhöflich wahrnehme.
Wenn es keine aufhaben soll warum habt ihr keine maske auf leute so ja ich meine ist ja jetzt nicht so dass dass das in berlin die leute jetzt immer mit so einem,
empathischen lächeln rumlaufen was ich dann vermissen würde gewisser hinsicht wird die griesgrämig,
jetzt einfach mal überdeckt und dadurch ändert sich dann unterm strich auch nicht viel.
Scheint für deutschland speziell kulturell irgendwie besonders schwierig zu sein so von wegen was hat jetzt zu verbergen und sonst maskiert sind halt banditen und so das.
Ja ja genau vermummungsverbot und so weiter.
Und vermummungsverbot der kann ja nichts gutes im schilde führen warum zeigt er nicht sein gesicht.
Bankräuber.
Ja
Ne und dass das den den zwitschi müssen wir glaube ich alle so in den köpfen hinkriegen weil wie du richtig sagtest symptome im schnitt
ab dem fünften tag infektiös im schnitt signifikant schon ab dem zweiten tag in bestimmten einzelfällen schon am ersten tag
und von daher ist es sehr wahrscheinlich dass man zwei drei tage rumläuft ohne was zu merken und bereits ansteckend ist und da hilft auch
keine quarantäne und auch kontakt nachverfolgen wird.
Halt schwierig so und.
Zum thema masken fällt mir noch ein das ganze thema abi-prüfungen jetzt in verschiedenen auch in berlin wird jetzt diskutiert wie die stattfinden
und generell thema schulen öffnen gut aber speziell zu den abi-prüfungen,
ja die sollen halt in innenräumen stattfinden und.
Zwar mit abstand des hilft sicherlich auch
aber eigentlich finde ich es im moment gerade eher unzumutbar vor dem hintergrund wissen wie es sich ausbreitet und dass es unter speziellen situationen auch airborne
werden,
kann ist es eigentlich eine risiko situation im moment wo ich finde wenn man ihn unbedingt abiturprüfung machen will denn nicht ohne.
Dass jeder 'ne maske hat und das weiß ich nicht ob das wiederum wirklich zumutbar ist so mit einer maske,
leute zu prüfen und eigentlich gibt's dafür auch eine ganz einfache lösung ich meine man hat ja
die ganzen noten aus einigen jahren so kann ich den leuten dann also entweder einfach einen abitur
ohne prüfung ausstellen mit dem schnitt den sie bisher sowieso schon haben und bei denen die das nicht wollen die können dann halt später geprüft werden weil letztlich ist es
eine frage alles der,
auch der zahlen wann man das ganze lockern kann wenn wir erstmal saßen vor china jetzt ist mir nämlich mit einstelligen zuwachs raten dann ist das risiko auch eher gering sich.
Anzustecken und dann kann man auch wieder durchaus an sowas denken aber.
Das liegt weil wir auch langsamer bremsen habe ich das gefühl selbst wenn wir die maßnahmen jetzt aufrecht erhalten
bis wir
darunter sind dass wir so einstellige zuwachs raten haben das sind noch so zwei monate ungefähr nach meinen berechnungen bis zu sagen wir ja wenn
wenn wir nicht vorher zu viele maßnahmen wieder aufheben und der sagen.
Und der rückgang langsamer erläuft oder gar wieder ansteigt also unter jetztigen bedingungen werden es zwei monate bis wir.
Auf einen sicheren level runter sind.
Was auch noch aufkam das vielleicht mal so zum abschluss der masken- diskussion ist ja auch so.
Wie sollte man die masken waschen so es gibt eine relativ einfache lösung man kann die auch einfach bügeln.
Denn die viren werden so definitiv bei siebzig grad sind die dann irgendwie weg und wer so eine maske schon mal in die waschmaschine geschmissen hat da sind
kommt dann ziemlich häufig ein elender wieder raus also man kann die halt auch einfach mal bügeln dann sind sie nicht nur schick aus sondern sind dann eben auch weitgehend.
Viren frei also was heißt weitgehend also wenn man gut.
Guter tipp ja.
Gut bügelt dann sind sie halt wieder frei.
Ja und wie gesagt die die die wissen ja auch dass sie ohnehin nicht so super robust sind die viren insofern sollte das eigentlich ist das ein guter tipp.
Und man sollte natürlich jeder seine eigene maske haben das.
Ja
Masken sharing ist jetzt noch nicht angesagt.
Gut was jetzt auch schon anklang in dem was wir gesagt haben ist wir werden jetzt früher oder später in eine andere phase eintreten ne also wir werden irgendwann einen punkt erreicht haben wo man sagt okay
die ganz krasse maßnahme mit dem man jetzt alles erstmal zurückfährt und diese neu ansteckungsrisiko rate weitgehend unter eins drückt.
Das virus wird nicht komplett verschwinden das wissen wir glaube ich auch sprich irgendwie wenn man halt.
Wieder seine alten gepflogenheiten aufnimmt
dann steigt automatisch natürlich wieder das risiko wieder in eine solche situation zu kommen wie wir jetzt eben noch sind da wollen wir nicht hin ergo muss erstmal operativ das land.
Jedes land in einen anderen modus gehen und dieser modus ist schlicht der.
Möglichst früh entdecken wo eine ausbreitung stattgefunden hat also wo jemand symptome zeigt dann natürlich testen sprich.
In der lage sein möglichst schnell ein tests auch durchführen zu können ganz klar.
Aber eben die frage ist wie findet man die und vor allem in hinblick auch nochmal auf diese inkubation zeit.
In der man eben schon lange ansteckend ist wie kann man dann eben zusehen dass man auch alle leute mit denen diese person.
In kontakt getreten ist oder potenziell in kontakt getreten sein könnte wie kann man die eben finden.
Und ja dazu gab es ja dann auch eine.
Andere diskussion die mittlerweile breit geführt wird in der öffentlichkeit und die hier auch in der metaebene vor allem bei logbuch netzpolitik auch schon aufgegriffen wurde nämlich die unterstützung durch digitale systeme konkret durch eine app auf.
Einem handy du hast in die sendung die ich mit dem minus gemacht habe sicherlich angehört.
Und was ihr auch richtig festgestellt habt ist das tracking über positions
daten technisch einen riesen problem ist also über gps und
wlan tracking des saugt dir einfach den akku leer wenn du das in zu häufigen zeitabständen machst so und.
In innenräumen ja die problematik habt ihr auch gut.
Beschrieben grade in städten wo leute übereinander wohnen und in innenräumen funktioniert gps nicht und die wlan ortung und,
selbst wenn ich irgendwie mit meinem nachbarn also ich würde mit mit hunderten oder tausenden von von leuten quasi in kontakt getreten sein obwohl ich.
Virtuell obwohl ich nie wirklich kontakt
mit denen hatte weil ich nie mit dem in einem raum war weil wir durch wände und wohnungen und stockwerke getrennt sind und so und das sind einfach dann zu viele und dasselbe
gilt auch für jetzt
oder in einem größeren maße fast noch wenn ich die daten jetzt bei irgendwelchen providern abgreifen sagen die positionsdatenströme was ja lange andere erwägung ist die die.
Provider sollen die daten liefern die sind eher noch von schlechterer qualität so oder im besten fall genauso schlecht wie wenn ich die daten selber sammle und da gab's,
ja dann eben diesen ansatz des über bluetooth beacons zu machen so wie das wohl auch in singapur eine recht erfolgreiche app macht tracks und ja.
Das scheint tatsächlich wenn überhaupt der einzige ansatz zu sein wo man nicht von vornherein gleich sagen kann,
vergesst es so also quasi zwangs tracking so ist die datenqualität.
Einfach nicht gut genug was die app angeht ich habe.
Eine ganze menge erfahrungen mit eben gps und wlan tracking also hinreichend um zu sagen es funktioniert nicht,
was jetzt bluetooths beacons angeht habe ich ein bisschen erfahrung aus anderen anwendungskonzepte nämlich die museen über die ja auch gesprochen habt wo.
Man hat ja geht,
so ich würde mir tatsächlich aber in der praxis auch nicht allzu viel davon erwarten aus einer ganzen reihe von gründen nicht sagen würde man soll's nicht probieren so.
Aber es gibt da einfach auch ganz ganz
viele potenzielle probleme die ich dich sehe an angefangen einfach damit dass alle das nennenswerter teil der leute einfach mit dieser app
dass sie sich dass die die installieren müssen und dass die die laufen lassen müssen,
das sehe ich so fast als das größte problem plus
was ja auch nicht also mehrere länder habe ich ja dann gelesen bauen jetzt auch aus so einer app und wir bauen auch an einer wo ich mir dann erstmal die gefragt habe okay
was haben wir denn jetzt.
Eine app für jedes land und wenn wir dann reisen müssen uns dann vorher die app für das entsprechende tracing app für das entsprechende land runterladen wäre es nicht eigentlich sinnvoller eine app für die ganze welt zu haben so
und wenn man jetzt eine app macht wäre es nicht möglich wenn das einfachste ist
das ding aus singapur zu nehmen ich habe mir das jetzt noch nicht im detail angeguckt und wie das ist mit pro prioritär code und ob das was taugt oder nicht überhaupt aber es scheint ja zumindest auch dort eine daten sparsame lösung eigentlich.
Die gewählt haben so wie sie an diskutiert
wurde warum dann nicht sagen wir wir nehmen den marktführer oder die zensieren vom marktführer und wenn man das was wahrscheinlich nicht gelingen wird aus verschiedensten gründen weil,
dann sollte man wenigstens überlegen ob man's nicht interoperabel macht das sagen die verschiedenen apps dass ich meine app dann auch.
So auf der ganzen welt benutzen kann aber das macht natürlich auch dann
jede menge probleme plus die freigabe durch den arzt ist auch noch so eine so eine engstelle insofern ja.
Ich würde nicht sagen wir wir sollen wir sollten es versuchen
ich sehe darin aber nicht jetzt die rettung sondern im besten fall einen unterstützendes ding was in ein paar prozent der fälle tatsächlich helfen kann aber es wird wir werden es nicht technisch lösen mit einer app das problem.
Ja
okay ich sage dann mal ein paar sachen dazu also erstmal vielleicht zur orientierung für die leute die in dieser ganzen diskussion bisher noch nicht so gefolgt sind mal so eine ganz grobe idee landschaft ne also bluetooth als technologie
bietet sich insofern erstmal an als dass es eben von vornherein etwas ist was eben funktioniert.
Eben für den naherer und gedacht ist also bluetooth ist genau in diesem ein paar meter bereich über den wir jetzt die ganze zeit
über infektionsweg etcetera dort wird bluetooth eben
und jeder der mal mit einem bluetooth-kopfhörer zu weit von seinem telefon weggegangen ist weiß irgendwann ist halt schluss na da sind natürlich wände und scheiben und sowas alles ein problem aber eben auch die reine distanz.
Von dem eingeschränkten maße kann man aber auch aus einem bluetooth signal auch noch herauslesen wie weit denn nun etwas weg ist
entweder indem man halt signal stärken abwägt aber wahrscheinlich auch sehr viel effizienter das macht's aber technisch auch nochmal ein bisschen aufwendiger indem man eben komplette.
Reichweiten messungen macht also quasi signale hin und her schickt und dann eben schaut wie lange haben die gebraucht und wenn man dann sozusagen die zeit misst dann hat man relativ.
Gute erkenntnisse darüber das erfordert aber dann eben auch noch eine kooperation das heißt dann reicht es nicht nur einfach daten einzusammeln,
sondern dann muss man eben auch interoperabel
haben die dann in dem moment auch aktiv werden etcetera und das dürfte noch sehr viel schwieriger sein als eben dieses reine einsammeln von all dies.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist destotrotz ist es schon,
in meinen augen ein ein weg den man eben mal ausprobieren sollte selbst wenn man nur feststellt,
das nicht geht man auch das wäre ja mal ein wissenschaftlicher gewinn bevor man es nicht ausprobiert hat kann man es auch nicht so richtig wissen weil
könnte auch sein dass es hilft hilft im sinne nicht von dass es eben die lösung für alles ist dass es einfach auch nur unterstützend ist.
Es ist schon eine information wenn man jetzt einen fall hat und versucht den nach zu recherchieren okay war.
Diese person überhaupt in der nähe von irgendjemand anderem kann ja auch sich herausstellen war gar nicht ja es kann aber auch sein.
Es gab sehr viel kontakt also allein die pure menge ist natürlich auch schon mal eine unterstützende information wenn auch nur im nachgang in einer statistischen auswertung also ich sehe da schon einen gewissen wert
ich habe aber ein paar fragen die mir in der ganzen diskussion bisher noch ein bisschen zu kurz gekommen sind jetzt wird's vielleicht ein bisschen technischer auch.
Wenn du damit gearbeitet hast wie es in deiner erfahrung welchen zugriff auf bluetooth.
Betriebssysteme derzeit den apps überhaupt gewähren.
Die erforderlich wären um sowas technisch durchzuführen es gibt ja da allerlei restriktionen interessanterweise eben auch aus solchen datenschutz.
Begründung heraus.
Ich,
wollte eigentlich hatte ich überlegt gestern mal so eine kleine app zu hacken die das die das macht so um um das mal selber praktisch auszuprobieren und die api genau zu verstehen
aber also die aktuelle weil da hat sich halt auch eine ganze menge geändert früher war es halt schwierig also grundsätzlich kann ich halt wenn ich
sondern bluetooth speaken habe kann ich seine sender stärke einstellen sprich wie weit
der überhaupt ausstrahlen soll und dann bekomme ich noch auf der gegenseite dann auch noch mit wenden bieten da ist wie die empfangsstation bei mir war und ich glaube auch die sende stärke wird mit
übertragen sodass ich dann tatsächlich.
Ganz gut auf die entfernung schließen kann und ich glaube man kann es bis auf bei der niedrigsten einstellung ist es einen meter
ungefähr wobei das halt davon abhängt natürlich auch ob ich meinen körper zwischen
dem gerät und dem anderen gerät also wieviel wieviel körper sich dazwischen befindet und wie
dass das beeinflusst dann doch die feldstärke nochmal erheblich so also wie wie,
telefone und körper eben zueinander sind aber sollte jetzt kein kein killer kriterium sein was jetzt,
die möglichkeit angeht.
Wenn wenn jetzt ein bieten detektiert wird kann ich halt im betriebssystem meine app registrieren dass sie doch bitte bei einer bestimmten art von
blicken doch bitte aktiv wird also bei unter kenne mich besser mit eiweiß als mit mit android aus aber da ist grundsätzlich so dass ich
halt ja sachen registrieren kann denn und dann.
Kann ich aber erstmal nicht allzu viel machen ich kann auch ein bisschen code tatsächlich ausführen dann es sollte wahrscheinlich reichen um
die daten weg zu schreiben aber grundsätzlich kann es sein dass es nicht ohne
ohne pop-up also ohne wenn die app aktiviert wird dass ich dann irgendwie bestätigen muss dass er mir halt anzeigt hier ist ein bieten will zu irgendwie
auf diesen bieten jetzt reagieren oder so wenn die app nicht läuft das könnte sein das wollte ich halt ausprobieren ob dem dem so ist oder nicht ich vermute nicht kriegt es wahrscheinlich auch komplett im hintergrund
hin das sollte mit den aktuellen versionen eigentlich gehen und unter
android eigentlich auch vor allen dingen wenn ich's nicht sekündlich brauche die die.
Informationen so also ich bin der meinung technisch sollte es funktionieren grundsätzlich
ganz offenbar wissen wir dass es in singapur ja auch.
Funktioniert das sie's halt hingekriegt habe mal geguckt ob man die app runterladen kann eigentlich aus singapur in unserem deutschen shop.
Sieht trails die habe ich noch nicht probiert kann ich mal machen aber ich glaube nicht.
Weil das war nämlich auch so ein ding was ich mal jetzt probieren wollte
einfach mal zu sehen um zu dem thema aber ich meine schon richtig sagtest es kann einen ergänzendes ding sein aber es wird.
Alleine definitiv nicht ausreichend und wieviel prozent da müsste man,
dann jetzt auch mal genauer die daten der gesundheitsämtern kennen zu gucken die haben ja jetzt in ganz vielen fällen,
kontakte eingesammelt hat er bisher so funktioniert wenn jemand.
Infiziert war also wenn jemand eine diagnose gekriegt hat wurde das dem gesundheitsamt gemeldet und derjenige musste ein formular ausfüllen und dort die adressen,
mit allen leuten angeben von allen leuten angeben
mit denen er jetzt kontakt hatte und die wurden dann eben auch kontaktiert und mussten wiederum dann auch nochmal den kontakt irgendwie qualifizieren und sich in selbst quarantäne begeben so das war.
Halt so bisher der mechanismus und da ist sie die frage okay wie in wie viel prozent der fälle
ist es eigentlich möglich gewesen nachzuvollziehen wo sich derjenige und wann sich derjenige angesteckt hat und,
ich hab so das gefühl so in der hälfte der fälle konnte das ungefähr nachvollzogen
werden das heißt für die andere hälfte der der fälle wo man halt nichts weiß könnte das dann tatsächlich eine hilfe sein auch.
Vielleicht sogar rückwirkend dann zu sehen und leute ausfindig zu machen
wo man sich angesteckt hat möglicherweise und andere äste abzuschneiden der infektionsweg e wenn das gelingen würde wobei so out of the box
wäre das jetzt mit den super datensparsamkeit konzept erstmal mia.
Gut würde sicherlich teilweise helfen wenn die leute dann benachrichtigt werden und sich dann selber testen lassen so also insofern könnte das helfen ein paar zweige abzuschneiden und wir wissen im zweifelsfall
würde es reichen wenn diese app genau eine person stoppt nämlich die letzte oder die erste
die diesen virus hat um das problem,
zu lösen also insofern ja das sind jetzt sehr hypothetisch aber auch
wahrscheinlich selbst eine kleine zahl von von fällen weil sich das ja exponentiell ausbreitet ist halt jeder einzelne infizierte
quarantäne zu stellen kann halt
neue epidemie verhindern oder einen komplett neuen ausbruch insofern könnte ist es doch wert sein selbst wenn wir am ende nur ein paar selbst wenn wir am ende zehn oder hundert,
leute mit dem system nur ausfindig machen so kannst du es wert sein.
Das denke ich auch ne
also diese trades together als solche ist nicht im app store im deutschen verfügbar tatsächlich habe ich jetzt auf anhieb nur eine gefunden die in abu dhabi unter dem namen traces heraus
wird von der ich jetzt nicht genau weiß wie sie funktioniert in abu dhabi hätte ich jetzt nicht so viele hoffnung dass die jetzt besonders daten sparsam privatsphäre.
Implementiert ist aber na ja egal na ich bin auch nicht ganz so pessimistisch ehrlich gesagt was die potentielle verbreitung betrifft zumal wir ja hier auch.
Dadurch dass es so ein globales ding ist und ich würde jetzt mal ganz kurz mein blick ausschließlich auf die plattform richten bei android gibt's da noch ein paar andere probleme.
Ist ja nicht so dass apple jetzt auch noch nichts mitbekommen hätte davon dass es dieses problem gibt so und du kannst auch mal davon ausgehen dass jetzt auch nicht.
Zufällig weil sie den lkw oder logbuch netzpolitik reinhören von dieser diskussion was mitbekommen haben ich würde sogar so wie ich den laden kenne und
gerade auch wenn ich mir anschaue was ihr in den letzten tagen ja schon gemacht haben ich weiß es gibt jetzt auch der apple support webseite gibt's jetzt so
wie man unsere leser gekettet spritzschutz maske zusammenbaut videos und sowas ja also die sind da sowieso schon voll am start
und dieser laden hat auch extrem viel erfahrung bereits mit bluetooth tracking weil sie das ja für ihre eigenen systeme bereits benutzen.
Es gibt es gibt ja dieses device und so weiter das ist jetzt nicht exakt genau dasselbe modell aber das ist ein,
arbeit letztlich mit denselben techniken also hast du zusammengeklappten laptop irgendwo in der sofaritze liegen und weiß jetzt nicht wo das teil ist dann sendet das ding selbst in diesem zusammengeklappten zustand sogar noch was aus.
Man sagt hallo hilfe finde mich und tatsächlich können andere telefone also nicht das eigene können dieses ding orten leiten dann eben diese information
weiter an einem zentralen server in dem fall so dass wenn du eben sagst.
Meine herren wo habe ich denn meinen laptop liegen lassen das dann eben diese geo koordination den dem moment dann eben mit rausgegeben wird dann gefunden werden kann also anderer zweck auch.
Andere architektur aber letzten endes diese erfahrung ist da ich wäre also jetzt nicht so überrascht,
wenn wir sowas sehen würden wir ein betriebssystem-update in der nächsten zeit was explizit genau dieser kategorie von apps.
Hilfsmittel bereitstellt in irgendeiner form und wenn's nur eine neue security deklaration ist mit okay.
Diese apps brauchen jetzt einen bestimmten zugang zu informationen den wir so bisher nicht gegeben haben ja.
Höhere anzahl von beacons die gleichzeitig beobachtet werden können erlaubnisse im hintergrund zu laufen und so weiter also all diese limitierung die wir jetzt vielleicht
kann sein dass die morgen für eine bestimmte kategorie von apps in dem fall halt die von einem land
oder eben der uno oder wer auch immer herausgegeben den offiziellen apps dass die eben explizit ihren segen bekommen mit ok.
Normalerweise machen wir das ja mal nicht aber jetzt haben wir halt mal krise die dürfen das jetzt
die dürfen einen schritt weitergehen und im rahmen bestimmter parameter dürfen die eben jetzt hier drei prozent mehr akku verbrauchen dürfen auf bestimmte daten zugreifen
oder noch besser,
die müssen das gar nicht selber tun sondern es gibt jetzt ein stück brot im betriebssystem der quasi diese ganze sammlung einfach im hintergrund schon macht.
Die nur einmal irgendwie getriggert werden muss und die app muss überhaupt nicht laufen sondern die wird nur was weiß ich,
alle stunde mal aufgeweckt und kriegt neuen datenströme zugeliefert mit hier gucke mal habe ich für dich eingesammelt brauchtest du gar nicht viel für machen da hast du mach was du für richtig hältst also
das sehe ich schon als eine möglichkeit an.
Das ist jetzt in diesem entschuldigung noch eine sache das ist natürlich in diesem apple universum jetzt relativ einfach zu machen weil apple da halt unter vollständiger kontrolle ist und vor allem weil großer vorteil
hier auch schon
naja ich würd mal sagen sowas wie achtundneunzig prozent aller im betrieb befindlichen telefone nicht älter sind als zwei drei jahre und davon eben der großteil auch schon die alle neuesten.
Betriebssysteme fährt.
Und dann könnte man eben wenn man sagt okay das bauen wir jetzt hier auch noch in dem letzten betriebssystem ein etcetera könnte man im relativ schnell überall ein software-update das in die welt bringen.
Also wie gesagt grundsätzlich also ich habe keine frage dass es ist für mich keine frage dass es funktioniert ich meine face to go
die machen das fest die machen das so insofern geht es jetzt schon
es kann nur besser werden so also mit weniger stromverbrauch und weniger nachteilen und zuverlässige aber grundsätzlich gehe ich davon aus
es geht unter android und unter unter ios jetzt schon und die rest probleme auch davon aus dass es halt
ja zuverlässiger und energiesparender tendenziell eher wird.
Ich rechne auch mit einem standard so keine ahnung ob triple oder irgendjemand anderer aber ich denke mal dass da irgendwas standardisiert werden wird und.
Das spannende natürlich wird dann sein wie dann aber die sagen surver infrastruktur dazu tatsächlich
aussieht und wenn man das halt auf einer globalen ebene machen möchte.
Die datenmengen gehen so also für für für deutschland habe ich mal,
geguckt ist so ein datensatz von vierzehn tagen für zwanzig millionen.
Leute sind so hundert gigabyte ungefähr das ist jetzt nicht wirklich wild so.
Gespeichert werden es reicht ja vollkommen wenn es auf dem telefon gespeichert wird.
Genau ja größenordnung na ja gut aber ich muss halt schon jetzt für das sagen für das matchen also wenn ich benachrichtigt werden will muss ich ja ich muss ja meine daten halt schon.
Sagen egal ob dezentral oder nicht muss ich sie irgendwo hinlegen wo sie für einen anderen erreichbar sind der dann sagen erkrankt ist,
so sonst werde ich nicht benachrichtigt ich könnte natürlich wenn es jetzt nur so ist dass nur die infizierten sagen ihre ihre daten hinterlegen denn.
Kann ich halt nicht benachrichtigt werden dann müsste ich halt.
Sagen meine daten sagen nur auf anfrage übermitteln also wer aber in dem moment wenn ich neugierig bin oder benachrichtigt werden will muss ich halt meine daten ja auch auf dem server hinterlegen irgendwo das haar.
Na ja du musst halt nur muss halt nur regelmäßig nachfragen ob es was für dich gibt ja also.
Okay gut ich kann halt nachfragen ja liegt da meine irgendwo vor aber ja.
Vielleicht an der stelle wir wollten wir wollten ja da könnte man vielleicht dann noch eine eigene sendung zu machen wenn ich einen.
Vielleicht einen kleinen prototyp gehackt hab oder,
oder so ja es hat halt viele viele implikationen wo auch von der bedienung und benutzung her und so spielt spielt da natürlich auch immer mit rein lösbar ist das problem
und es ist daten sparsam lösbar und wir sollten es lösen.
Genau da können wir ja dann vielleicht nächste woche nochmal draufschauen zum schluss kann man ja nochmal so ein bisschen darüber grübeln was.
Was da so alles für auswirkungen auf uns haben wird.
Insbesondere in ein digitaler hinsicht das ist ja vielleicht so ein positiver aspekt den man dabei noch dem ganzen abgewinnen kann dass man jetzt irgendwie keinen mehr klar machen muss das internet eine ganz gute idee ist eigentlich.
Ich wurde ja irgendwie noch vor kurzem.
Ausgelacht als ich gefordert habe dass wir eigentlich das dass jeder einen gigabitanschluss zuhause braucht eigentlich dass das sozusagen der unterste mindeststandard sein soll.
In beide richtungen naja in beide richtungen.
Da bin ich noch vor vor zwei tagen oft wird dafür ausgelacht worden.
Ok ja ja weil irgendwie wozu und warum ich meine wir sehen es halt jetzt einfach gerade mit dem ganzen home-office.
Wo videokonferenzen ins stocken geraten wo,
leute mit remote desktop so arbeiten die teilweise extrem langsam sind wo,
uploads von dokumenten oder so von größeren ewig dauern also all die die dinge selbst für einen einzelnen zu hause gut da könnte man sagen okay mit.
Eigentlich mit so einem v mit einem v d oder mit einem ordentlichen kabelanschluss oder so sollte eigentlich die bandbreite.
Reichen aber.
Bei firmen haben wir es halt ganz schnell gesehen ganz viele institutionen die mit einem gigabit angebunden sind wo das vorne wo das gigabit vorne und hinten nicht reicht also für firmen ist ein gigabit
die absolute untergrenze definitiv aktuell gerade.
Und wenn ja wenn plötzlich.
Pro tausend mitarbeiter.
Na ich würde würde eher sollten sagen so pro,
hundert maximal also ich glaube mit einem gigabit kannst du maximal hundert mitarbeiter je nachdem was sie machen vielleicht auch auch weniger so versorgen ich weiß ich kenne halt.
Eine firma in der größenordnung die mit dem gigabit link ganz gut fährt aber ja.
Aber wenn du wenn man größer ist reicht halt das selbst das gigabit nicht aus und ich fand es ja also da muss ich jetzt.
Nochmal sagen was,
gerade so alles unter dem thema podcast von den öffentlich-rechtlichen beworben wird verdient.
Aus meiner sicht dieses label gar nicht oder zu zumindest hätte ich erwartet dass dort wenigstens eine vernünftige audioqualität,
herrscht oder eine brauchbar aber die sind überhaupt nicht darauf,
vorbereitet offensichtlich über das internet irgendwelche sprachaufnahmen zu machen und gerade irgendwie,
war jetzt sogar so high profile podcast die zwanzig millionen mal gehört werden von immunologe von trosten von dem,
coole oder wie der heißt und anderen da knackt es so weil offensichtlich ja
die übers wlan oder
wie auch immer weil die leitungen überlastet sind da brechen die übertragung unterwegs zusammen dann wird per telefon weitergemacht und ja trotz voice hd kriegen sie es dann auch noch hin dass sie offensichtlich im studio.
H d voice
fegen code haben wenn jemand vom mobiltelefon anruft sondern das ganze auf acht also ein trauerspiel ein wirkliches trauerspiel so und das macht mich halt auch wütend,
so wenn ich sehe dass die irgendwie sieben milliarden zur verfügung haben und fucking audio nicht auf die reihe kriegen ja
dass das so das macht mich echt wütend so.
Ja das ist in der tat frappierend so vielleicht bleiben wir nochmal ganz kurz bei der.
Frage mit dem internet anschluss ne und warum ein gigabit eigentlich eine gute idee ist weil ich glaube das verstehen wirklich auch viele leute nicht und man wird natürlich dann auch schnell wenn man sowas für sich fordert.
Gleich von zwei leuten angegangen also erstmal die front mit ich habe ja viel weniger und das reicht für mich.
Das ist so die die die eine seite und die andere ist du ich habe ja noch nicht mal ein zettel von dem mit dem du jetzt gerade unzufrieden bist was fällt dir überhaupt ein noch mehr zu fordern
und das sind natürlich zwei nachvollziehbare perspektiven trotzdem kann man ihn glaube ich.
Mal ein paar argumente entgegen schicken worum es trotzdem sehr angemessen ist diese forderung zu stellen und nicht nur weil andere länder das schon haben.
Ja so also einfach mal so aus dieser aus dieser warum das eigentlich eine gute idee ist erstmal gibt es mehrere aspekte es gibt die bandbreite.
Und es gibt die asymmetrie und es gibt die zuverlässigkeit die bandbreite ja,
klar wir sehen das ja alle seit längerer zeit da werden halt so internetanschlüsse beworben ja hier mit irgendwie fünfhundert megabits zweihundert megabit keine ahnung irgendwelche zahlen werden durch den raum geschmissen voll der geile schneller anschluss
so da haben wir die kabel provider teilweise noch immer die nase vorn weil die natürlich über dieses,
fernsehen kam was ja ein kroatia kabel ist was an sich so für hochfrequent,
ausgelegt ist und von daher eben auch hohe datenraten ganz gut annehmen kann da hat sie auch die technik natürlich immer weiter verbessert das heißt die kriegen da tatsächlich wirklich hohe geschwindigkeiten durch.
Hallo
nur ist das natürlich auch ein medium das heißt umso mehr leute auf diesem kabel drauf sind umso mehr senkt sich das ganze und diese ganzen zusagen mit hohen datenraten das wird sich natürlich in dem moment dann wiederum anders verhalten wenn dann eben auch wirklich viele leute an einem strang diese daten ab
berufen die dsl hat andere probleme ja kann meistens diese hohen leitung nicht machen hat aber dann nicht so sehr das
probleme mit dem gemeinsamen zugriff von vielen leuten weil jeder quasi sein eigenes kabel hat bis zu einer verteiler box und dann hängt es eben von der
von dem anschluss dieser verteiler box ab.
Gemein haben die beiden verfahren aber dass eben in der regel diese ganzen hochgeschwindigkeitszug angebote deshalb gemacht werden können wenn man auf der anderen seite bei der upload geschwindigkeit kürzt also man bietet viel an,
damit man irgendwie eine große zahl hat mit der man werben kann dementsprechend ist aber dann die upload geschwindigkeit weil es geht ja dann quasi
auf demselben medium weg ne und du hast nur so und so viel kapazität und dann ist es sozusagen die frage okay wieviel der zeit
die hier daten gesendet werden lässt du in die eine richtung daten durch und wie viel in die andere richtung und alle sagen halt immer download download download downloaden wir wollen hier hohe zahlen haben dann können wir nicht so viel upload anbieten
dementsprechend sieht das dann eben so ein bisschen arm aus kommen die leute sagen naja,
das ist doch genau meine anwendung hier youtube und so weiter ich will ja runterladen netflix gucken und so weiter stimmt auch,
absolut richtig und ich sage auch gar nicht man muss jetzt nicht man muss grundsätzlich auf asymmetrie verzichten.
Zugunsten von download aber es wäre doch teilweise sehr angemessen wenn man dann vielleicht mal das verhältnis ein wenig anpasst denn es gibt ja auch
upload bedarf und genau das sehen wir jetzt in dieser aktuellen situation leute wollen jetzt auch mal in die andere richtung was schicken weil sie ein videokonferenzen teilnehmen und so wie das technisch auch funktioniert ist es ja auch heute so
da nicht alles über zentrale server abgewickelt werden kann weil die ja dann auch glühen ist der bedarf dass wenn man jetzt.
Leuten eine videokonferenz hat ist der bedarf dass man sein eigenes signal vielleicht an mehr als eine person schickt,
damit es die schnell erreicht damit die latenzen auch niedrig sind der steigt das heißt ich habe dann auch wieder einen erhöhten bedarf an an ablenkt.
Außerdem heißt ja zu hause arbeiten nicht nur,
ich habe jetzt hier so mein remote screen und arbeite auf meinem arbeitsrechner aus der ferne das ist tatsächlich etwas was man jetzt wahrscheinlich sehr oft findet weil das quasi der schnellste weg ist ja das heißt ja dann vielleicht auch,
okay ich arbeite jetzt hier das heißt ich erzeuge hier daten die muss ich dann auch anderen leuten bereitstellen.
Ich muss auch regelmäßig backups machen ich muss irgendwie diese daten die ich jetzt hier geschaffen habe was weiß ich ich schneide den film
andere leute sollen in sich anschauen ja der nächste schritt in einem verarbeitungsprozess review was auch immer muss stattfinden
wenn ich dann so ein paar gigabyte daten erzeugt habe die dann mal fünf minuten später von irgendjemand anderes angeschaut werden soll dann stehe ich da mit meinem schlechten,
blink und kriegt diese daten dann halt erstmal nur in einer stunde hoch und was jetzt noch dazukommt ist.
Was auch viele leute nicht sehen dass trotz dieser ganzen angeblichen hohen geschwindigkeiten die da angeboten werden die fehler raten auf diesen kupfer leitungen und auch teilweise auch auf diesem fernseher leitung relativ hoch sind.
Das heißt das äußert sich dann eben darin dass entweder die live.
Daten die schicke also streaming videokonferenz et cetera dann sehr viele anfällig sind was ich dann eben in diesen ton aussetzern oder bild aussetzern die nicht ganz so schlimm sind äußert.
Beziehungsweise bei uploads müssen dann halt auch immer wieder mal vorgänge wiederholt werden müssen neu gestartet werden und da die software auch nicht unbedingt immer sehr
nicht unbedingt darauf ausgelegt ist jetzt mit so hohen fehler raten gut klarzukommen
führt das dann auch mal schnell dazu dass ich sage okay ich lade hier mal was hoch dreck irgendwas in irgendeine webseite rein dann ist es halt ein dickes pfeil und da hat man zu achtzig prozent übertragung sagte sie ja fehler error fangen noch mal an
so und dann steht man halt schön doof da sprich.
Gute argumente warum man erstens symmetrische anschlüsse haben möchte also die gleiche geschwindigkeit oder zumindest annähernd die gleiche geschwindigkeit in in beide richtungen.
Und.
Dass wir eben auch einfach mal wegkommen von diesem ganzen kupfer ja egal ob es jetzt in form eines kamels wie beim fernsehen kam vorliegt oder eben dass die alte telefonanfragen struktur mit dsl das ist halt einfach.
Der skaliert einfach nicht so und deswegen brauchen wir einfach eine glasfaser infrastruktur.
Ja ich kann dir absolut recht geben vor ein paar monaten bin ich mal weil ich auch einen
eigenen videokonferenz server in betrieb genommen habe also es gibt da auch noch ein paar andere man kann
ist auch gar nicht so problematisch oder schwierig so ein ding zu den eigenen videokonferenz server zu betreiben
was halt insbesondere deswegen schön ist weil ich dann sicher sein kann dass sich auch private gespräche darüber führen kann und weiß dass die daten eben nur bei mir.
Landen so das gibt so und
dabei sind halt eben immer wieder rock klar aufgetreten und aussetzer und ich wollte dann wissen woran das liegt und habe
dann festgestellt dass ja die fehler raten doch erheblich.
Sind auf sowohl auf der dsl-anschluss seite wie auch in den netzen vom hoster teilweise gut hätte dann ein sehr billigen
hoster genommen aber ich war halt entsetzt darüber wie viele pakete verschwinden einfach und das auf sagen gleich dem
dem ersten übertragungswagen,
aus meiner wohnung raus zum zum kasten der da irgendwo auf der straße steht ja und
das ist also da fällt uns jetzt gerade auf die füße dass offensichtlich ja da geschludert wurde beziehungsweise die
die technik offenbar nicht so gut ist wie sie vielleicht auch sein könnte und.
Gut internet ist auf paket verluste ausgelegt so aber nicht
in dem master sich bin da teilweise auf raten von mehreren prozent gekommen an paketen die da einfach
verloren gehen und dachte zunächst es wäre ein technischer defekt aber wir haben dann auch bei anschlüssen von anderen leuten und zwischen und überall ging pakete verloren.
Das war nicht schön.
Also wir brauchen da auf jeden fall eine umorientierung weil so kann's einfach nicht weitergehen das ist einfach jetzt.
Klar geworden dass gerade in dem moment wo man es braucht,
diese infrastruktur einfach nicht das liefert was sie soll na klar es ist auch nicht so dass alle vor schwarzen bildschirm stehen gerade und eine menge leute gucken sich irgendwie gemütlich netflix an aber das ist halt auch nicht an alles und das ist halt auch das.
Um nochmal auf dieses.
Eine argument was mir dann so entgegen gehalten wird nochmal einzugehen mit diesem man braucht ja mehr nicht.
Das höre ich jetzt auch schon seit zwanzig jahren oder seit dreißig jahren eigentlich immer wieder je nachdem was du aktuell so der standard ist
wenn man nach dsl geschrien hat da waren die leute mit ihrem mode im glücklich und wussten überhaupt nicht was man sonst noch hätte anders mit dem internet machen können so nach dem motto meine webseite lädt doch was willst du denn eigentlich ah jetzt haben die auch alle irgendwie bilder drin und es dauert es lange so dann wurde es irgendwie klar d s l ist dann vielleicht dann doch mal eine ganz gute idee aber
wer braucht denn irgendwie mehr als ein megabits damals ich weiß nicht ich habe so was war das so mitte der.
Jetzt mal in den neunzigern anfang zweitausend muss das so gewesen da war ich bei unserer veranstaltung.
Und lustigerweise hieß die veranstaltung we want band witz so.
Es war irgendwie so eine podiumsdiskussion und alle schwadroniert und so ein bisschen darüber rum das ja ganz gerne ein bisschen mehr internet hätten.
Und mir war aber dann die diskussion trotzdem zu affig und ich habe dann einfach gesagt so leute wir brauchen jetzt einfach mal zwei megabit für alle in jede richtung.
So das war damals sozusagen noch die zukunft ne und dann ging das dann auch sofort wieder los somit.
Zwei megabit hast du sie noch alle.
Wer kann denn das benutzen wer hat denn da für einen bedarf so und vor allem für dieses symmetrische argument ne dass ich das sozusagen auch in die andere richtung haben möchte und fragt mich also ja.
Was willst du denn damit machen kann weil ich ja leute denk doch mal nach wie wär's denn mal mit backups.
Hm
Und das hat dann so ein leichtes gelächter ausgelöst bei den leuten ja erzähl erzähl das mal heute irgendjemanden dass da,
backup über das internet eine scheiß-idee ist so aber weil sie sich nicht vorstellen konnten dass man überhaupt dahin kommen könnte über sowas nachzudenken
und genauso ist es natürlich mit den geschwindigkeiten die wir heute haben auch warum gibt's denn keine guten anwendungen na ja weil die leute einfach keine ablad kapazität haben.
Wo jeder ein gigabit hat stellt sich doch das internet auch sofort darauf ein und es wird einfach ganz andere dienste geben die einem einfach so ein flüssiges arbeiten viel viel viel leichter machen als das derzeit ist.
Das ist genau das ist nämlich genau der
der punkt dass bestimmte dinge einfach erst kommen oder machbar sind oder überhaupt finanzierbar sind die entwicklung wenn hinreichend bandbreite zur verfügung
steht so das ist halt das problem.
Schadet ja scheiße ja auch an keinen wenn man seine internetdaten bandbreite nicht benutzt,
ja man kann ja ein gigabit zur verfügung gestellt bekommen und normalerweise vielleicht nur ein prozent der daten der daten vielleicht sogar noch weniger aktiv nutzen.
Völlig in ordnung stört ja dann auch keinen wenn der anschluss das könnte nur
wenn du es brauchst dann hast du's halt auch und das war ein eine eine andere an anderen begriff würde ich dann ganz gerne auch mit reinwerfen nämlich auch die latenz
viele sachen werden auch erst dadurch möglich dass dinge schnell hin und her gehen da geht's gar nicht mal mehr so sehr um die
bandbreite also gamer kennen dieses problem und wir haben ja seit jahr und tag bei dem internet providern gibt's dann immer noch so dieses gamer mit was man irgendwie setzen kann damit die latenz niedrig ist weil man halt möchte das finde ich an meiner maus rucke ja
diese bewegung der maus möglichst schnell bei irgendeinem gaming server auch ankommt was wird da gemacht in dem fall da wird ja nicht ein schnellerer anschluss gelegt.
Die schalten einfach die fehler korrektur aus das ist sozusagen das feature was man in dem moment hat wer ja mal ganz nett wenn wir irgendwie eine niedrige fehlerrate haben und trotzdem auch eine schnelle latenz das kann halt alles nur die glasfaser bringen.
Ich gebe dir recht natürlich ist es so ich sage mal das zu sagen dass das umgekehrte argument oder.
Ich muss natürlich
auch für bandbreite die ich nicht nutze für die mögliche bandbreite auch bezahlen das heißt es ist natürlich schon so eine sache dass auch und auch der technische fortschritt ermöglicht es nicht
eine beliebige also das beliebig zu skalieren für einen bestimmten preis sondern
ja wir haben halt einen gewissen technischen fortschritt aber man kann glaube ich feststellen.
Dass der technische fortschritt zumindest soweit gediegen ist das ist jetzt kein wirklichen grund gibt warum wir nicht ein gigabit.
Flächendeckend haben was so bauteile angeht und anderes und ja.
Fasern auslegen und so aber wenn's sowieso machen müssen und eigentlich ist die zeit längst reif dafür und andere länder da kann man jetzt zum eingangs argument zeigen's ja das ist einfach.
Deutlich besser geht als bei uns deutlich besser.
Ja und ich meine die ausgaben die wir jetzt haben.
Stellen alles in schatten was ist das in den letzten jahren gekostet hätte ja also da hätte man einfach mal zehn zwanzig milliarden in die hand genommen und gesagt so leute wir buddeln jetzt mal deutschland mal auf ja fünf jahre gibt's mal jetzt mal weniger platz auf den gehwegen.
Aber wir machen jetzt einfach mal überall mal noch rein ding da mann rohr rein schießen da mal ein paar glasfaser rein und die legen wir jetzt an jedes haus.
Überall in allen großen städten in allen dörfern ist uns auch scheißegal wenn das dorf zehn kilometer entfernt ist
wir machen das jetzt einfach mal das geht dann in die wasserrohre noch mit parallel mit rein oder strom überall wo einfach aufgemacht wird legen wir was dazu und das gehört dem staat.
Und das liegt dann erstmal darum das wird auch nicht schlecht.
So eine glasfaser ja die die kann lange halten so da ist nicht viel dran was kaputt gehen kann wenn's nicht gerade vom bagger durchtrennt wird und dann haben wir diese infrastruktur schon mal da,
und dann kann der markt kommen und sagen ja dann will ich aber ganz gerne mal internet
anschließend so aber dann musst du nicht die telekom für den anschluss erstmal die rechnung aufmachen was sie es kostet dieses dorf anzuschließen.
Was ist halt einfach angeschlossen und dann ergibt sich der preis einfach dann an der tür weil letzten endes diese unternehmen einfach diese leitung vom staat mieten.
Für ein bis zwei wochen shutdown kosten
könnten wir irgendwie jedem einen glasfaseranschluss spendieren wahrscheinlich so größenordnungsmäßigen also fünf milliarden am tag
so zwei wochen
siebzig milliarden so dafür kann man flächendeckend die republik mit glasfaser bis
also gut.
Es ist jetzt nicht so dass wir jetzt kein corona gehabt hätten wir alle schnelles internet gehabt hätten aber sagen.
In diesen dimensionen natürlich wenn es uns alleine nur die die produktivität ein bisschen ab mindert
kommt da halt auch sehr schnell verdammt viel zusammen und ich,
denke ich hoffe dass man diese pandemien hat jetzt in vielen köpfen für eine gewisse flexibilität gesorgt und ja,
können glaube ich nur hoffen dass es auch im bereich internet ausbau dann eher,
positive folgen hat wobei natürlich mein als
unschöne was natürlich unschön ist das ganze geld was jetzt verloren geht oder nicht erwirtschaftet wird weil man natürlich irgendwie nachzahlen müssen der staat verschuldet sich gerade massiv und
ja das.
Das wird irgendwann zurückfließen müssen dass das geld oder stellt sich also und das heißt irgendwann wird auch der punkt kommen wo möglicherweise weniger.
Zur verfügung steht in den staatshaushalte vor dann ja sparsamkeit
angesagt wird und der punkt wird wahrscheinlich auch bald kommen also irgendwann ich glaube wenn das schlimmste vorüber ist dann werden wir ganz andere diskussionen ganz andere unschöne diskussion noch haben.
Keine frage aber ich meine um nochmal beim internet zu bleiben und auch ein.
Zum schluss immer sehr schön wichtig bei seiner sendung eine optimistischen ausblick haben es gibt ja auch ein paar durchaus positive.
Ist auch schon mehrfach betont worden kann man ruhig auch nochmal betonen ne wenn man sich mal anschaut wie wenig flugzeuge ist gerade unterwegs sind wie viel wie wenig autos jetzt gerade weltweit unterwegs sind wie die ganze,
belastung der luft mit schadstoffen überall zurückgeht.
Klar das wird sich nicht dauerhaft zu halten und das wird auch alles wiederkommen aber es mal ganz interessant zu sehen welchen einfluss wir eigentlich tatsächlich haben wir werden jetzt irgendwie dieses jahr wahrscheinlich sogar unsere co zwei schaffen können weil wir
weniger maschinen laufen haben aber wir sehen ja jetzt auch
dass eben weniger verkehr durchaus auch nicht unbedingt immer bedeutet dass automatisch die wirtschaftsleistung der zurückgeht wenn halt so eine homeoffice situation immer realisiert wird also flexiblere.
Nutzung von arbeitskraft ne.
Oder nicht so stark zurückgeht auf auf jeden fall dass ja das ist definitiv einen punkt und.
Guten paar stimmen also.
Nochmal nach der finanzkrise mit der das ja immer so ein bisschen oder anfangs verglichen wurde die ja auch so ein globaler einschneidender event war der erstmal die wirtschaft fast überall in den keller
gedrückt hat hat es so zwei bis drei jahre gedauert bis ich beim luftverkehr die zahlen
wieder normalisiert haben bis der luftverkehr wieder auf der alten kurve
zurück war dasselbe bei sat eins damals wobei das halt hauptsächlich in asien der fall war da kann man vielleicht auch
schlüssel rausziehen das ist die länder die damals bei sat eins schon ziemlich gebeutelt
wurden diesmal alle bisschen besser klar gekommen sind weil sie ganz viele
dinge damals mit tracking und allem schon
mit screening an flughäfen und und und und und andere dinge eingeführt hatten und ich denke das können wir hier bei uns wahrscheinlich
auch erwarten dass wir auf zukünftige pandemien oder.
Oder epidemien deutlich besser vorbereitet sein werden in jeder richtung.
Gut paul ich denke jetzt können wir es auch zu ende bringen hier unser update war ja wieder lang genug.
Ich finde das ein ein gutes format warum selber auch mal ein paar gedanken zu sortieren und das zu reflektieren was die ganze zeit auf uns ein stößt.
Was machen wir dann nächste woche wieder.
Dann hoffentlich mit noch besseren zahlen.
Genau gut vielen dank pavel.
Und ja vielen dank fürs zuhören hier bei u k w nächste woche hier wieder dieses format zwischendurch vielleicht noch ein paar andere einblicke aus anderen bereichen.
Sich das so.